good morning ladies and
gentlemen if you all please rise to join
Allegiance I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
all can't reach this
chck
before we open the hearing on house
spill
101 uh we were going to wait about 10
minutes for our chairman however my
understanding is he is okay but it
sounds like the front of another car hit
the rear end of his car so we are going
to have to start without him but um it
appears we're okay so if it's okay with
you guys if you would just pardon me if
you see me looking down I'm just making
sure there isn't anything I don't need
to do for him
so at that time um we will open the
hearing for House Bill 1011 and
recognize the sponsor representative
morning I'm representative Jam ringham
40 which is CBR at Hampton um here to
introduce House Bill 1011 relative to
the priting male genital mutilation I am
not the prime sponsor I have no idea
about the bill so I'll leave their test
to
others thank you representative Jan is
there
anybody here with us this morning that
bill
no
okay representative
Canon
for the record my name is representative
Jerry Canon representing straford dist
District not
1812 which is summersworth and
Rollinsford I'm here in
U against the
bill um this this bill's a bill in
search of a
problem it doesn't the problem doesn't
exist in New Hampshire fact it doesn't
England at least I cannot find any
does I know of a number of children that
were under the age of 18 that were under
the care of Physicians and therapists um
as far as them being a transgender
individual and they were following uh
the standards of care published by the
world
professional um Association of
professionals those those three
individuals that I
knew did not experience surgical
procedures until after the age of
18 and they are perfectly normal
society it concerns me that this legis
this bill is proposing legislation that
would discriminate
against young
male Youth and their
families it doesn't talk about anyone
else outside of being male it doesn't
talk about inter sex people who may be
genitalia it's focused on one group
that's already protected by New
Hampshire
statute I'm especially
concerned that although this bill has no
financial information for the most part
because it's
unknown is that in past ing this
legislation you will subject the state
of New Hampshire to substantial legal
costs uh we are already seeing um in the
US especially
as people cross state lines to get care
for their
children currently Texas is suing the
state or
the um Seattle children center
for care that's provided to a child
whose family moved out of Texas and that
courts much of the care that's given to
our residents comes from
Massachusetts I know this to be true
because I got my
surgical procedures two years ago at at
Mass General I I also know that many of
the children who are getting
Professional
Care get that
care from outside the
state as well as experts within our
state um even though much of that is
therapeutic care but it's also working
with them to help them become
society at this point
um I don't have anything more to say on
this bill but I feel it's egregious to
the um the transgender population as a
whole and I'm concerned about um our
transgender Youth and what this means to
questions thank you madam chair um
Elliot Hospital said on their website
they with question they said that those
Services aren't provided but on their
website they say they provide top and
bottom surgery so we really and then you
said that um children are or people are
not getting this kind of care in New
Hampshire but then you said yet that
they are getting it from Professionals
in our state so we don't know what is
the what is actually happening they are
getting therapeutic
care you what is you what do you mean by
therapeutic care hormones or no what do
you can you iterate on therapeutic care
um oneon-one
psychological care working working with
folks to help cope with a a problem um
there may be Top surgery
however currently young women can get
Breast
Care that's not associated with being a
transgender in
individual and the same thing would be
true for top top surgical procedures as
far as breast augmentation uh for a
young man it just from an aesthetic
perspective um and and that has been
country are are you representative are
you talking about over
here are you talking about um like
pectoral implants for men is that what
you were talking about yes okay further
surgery short of surgery would would
these prohibitions uh affect any any of
the care you talked about uh therapeutic
hormonal and that kind of thing that is
short of surgery would would those kind
of because it mentions chemicals
would whatever effect chemicals have on
the human body um when it's involved
with the treatment would any of that
treatment be also um prohibited by this
bill I'm concerned that it might uh
currently hormone blockers just stall
the
development they don't change anything
associated with the male gen
genitalia um it's a pause in the cycle
and if the hormone blockers are stopped
the the cycle
continues so it it's not a it does not
change um physically
um what happens with you it just stalls
it at one point when they start their
homeown blockers thank
you represent Reed it is my
understanding that depending on what
stage of the Tanner scale of development
the the puberty blockers are started it
can in fact stop um de um puberty
completely can you explain or that
further it thank it stalls it it stops
IT and and it will start as soon as the
hormone blockers are
stopped that's been verified from the
world Professional Association of
transgender Health it's part of part of
the studies that they've done it does
not
change thank you Representatives
hormones are not on this bill so
let's what oh they are now they were oh
I think that meant chemical castration
but yeah um representative
Muse thank you for taking my question um
last week the house passed HB uh
619 um I'm curious about your opinion um
in terms of how the bills compare um and
is are they would you consider them to
be uh equally problematic is one more
problematic than the other and and and
why I I would feel that they're equally
Pro
problematic um both are focused in on um
procedures genital procedures for
underage under the age of um adulthood
um which
which in in New Hampshire the
um the medical organizations um even in
Massachusetts is they wait until a child
has reach the age of adulthood and can
consent to any um procedures that are
necessary for their
health thank you representative would
you um would you say that this this bill
considering the bill we just passed is
maybe redundant in its current
form
yes see you no further questions thank
you for your testimony thank you for
who's
Zano
we good good morning chairman Roy and
members of the committee I ask you to
oppose HB 1011 as a pediatric emergency
medicine physician I do not diagnose
gender or transgender related medical
conditions no Emergency Physician does I
am not the primary healthc care provider
for these
teenagers however I have cared for many
during my medical career and many are in
the emergency department for a
psychiatric
crisis I have often knelt by their
stretcher in the hallway of the
overcrowded emergency department trying
to help them understand that their life
has meaning that they have inherent
worth and
dignity that they deserve to feel
happiness and
love transgender adolescents are at a
significantly increased risk of suicide
attempts compared to adolescence who are
not transgender but it doesn't have to
be this way
gender affirming Healthcare is
life-saving for the transgender people
who receive it scientific research shows
this Healthcare is safe and effective
and it is endorsed by every reputable
Medical Association transgender youth
like all youth have the best chance to
thrive when they are supported and can
get doctor prescribed Medical Care they
need this legislation intentionally
seeks to Target the transgender
population while also interfering with
medical decisions advancing this bill
tells New Hampshire parents and
Physicians that medical practice is
controlled by the state politicians do
not belong in this conversation in
addition there are numerous consequences
of this harmful bill that would prohibit
Medical Care not explicitly
mentioned parents should be able to get
their adolescent the medical care they
need without facing felony charges or
threats that the state will remove their
teen from their
home this care is supported by the
American American Academy of Pediatrics
the American Medical Association and
more specifically the AMA advocates for
quote laws and policies to protect
access to evidence-based care for gender
dysphoria and quote uh opposes quote
laws and policies that criminalize
prohibit or otherwise impede the
provision of evidence-based gender
affirming care including those that
penalize parents and Guardians who
support minors seeking and or receiving
gender affirming care and further AMA
supports quote protections against
criminal civil and professional
liability for Physicians that provide
evidence-based care and patients who
receive such care as well as their
parents and
Guardians the AMA has specifically
spelled out that laws such as HB 1011
are harmful and should be stopped
medical experts and granite Staters
understand that the people who should be
making the decisions on their healthare
are patients parents and Guardians and
their doctors New Hampshire's doctors
are dedicated professionals who have
trained for years and sworn public Oaths
to provide the best possible care for
their patients and families this
unnecessary bill is another attempt at
state government overreach into the
patient provider relationship and needs
to be stopped I urge you to vote itl on
HB
thank you um doctor you're a doctor
correct I am a doctor are you licensed
to practice in New Hampshire yes I am
where did you get that
license what is that who issues the
license I have a New Hampshire State no
but who issues that license the New
Hampshire State Medical Board so
politicians do have a role in medicine
is that not
correct they my understanding is that
they initiate some of the licensing
requirements but the medic few things
don't they I mean are we not LIC
how many medical how many politicians
are on Medical Board no how many well we
wrote the law that created the medical
board and do we not decide what drugs
can be written
prescribed is that in this committee
absolutely yeah well this is the
criminal justice committee we we look at
drugs yeah so my point is is for your
comment to say that government has no
role in medicine that's not correct is
it I didn't say it had no role I said
that this bill is government overreach
actually at the beginning you did say
that but that's okay questions for the
doctor
seeing none thank
you
fo thank you chairman Roy and honorary
committee members for listening to our
testimonies today my name is Michelle
silly foisey and I live in in Temple New
Hampshire and I am here to oppose HB
1011 I a mother of six and also a
physical therapist the last 3 years my
full-time job has been being a
mom to my four youngest at first staying
home was due to the pandemic now it's
for a different reason my 16-year-old
has been struggling with many physical
and mental health issues over the past
three years this past year they
transitioned to homeschooling due to
their severe migraines unfortunately we
didn't realize at the time just how
severe our teens Depression was or that
they were also experiencing gender
dysphoria in March for the first time in
my presence they expressed they were
experiencing near constant Suicidal
Thoughts while at a physician visit
immediately we sought counseling for
them after beginning therapy they were
slowly able to talk more openly to us
about things in September they came to
me and asked if they were too old start
hormone therapy after that conversation
a huge weight lifted from our adolescent
mind we are now actively receiving care
from an endocrinologist olist and just
beginning hormone replacement therapy
also known as HRT to allow them to have
a more feminine body they feel at home
in my queer child has started their own
journey and I am here to support them
however I can witnessing the
self-isolation and severe depression
they have endured has been horrific and
painful as their mother a heartache I
hope few parents have to cope with we
are incredibly fortunate to continue to
have our adolescent here with us today
after their attempted suicide in October
I sat in a doctor's office well at their
side as they revealed details of that
attempt their attempt was before they
came to me about HRT before they were
able to express how loss they were
feeling in their own body now there is
finally light creeping through the
darkness they have been living in as
their mom I am able to feel hope again
for their future I am grateful every day
that their beautiful face is still here
for me to touch I know for certain they
would not be if it wasn't for the
compassionate essential gender affirming
care their father and I consented to
that they are now receiving I come
before you today to share this very
personal story to express my deep
concern for what this bill is attempting
to do I have learned a great deal during
the course of the past year through this
experience with my teen always being a
strong supporter of LGB lgbtqia plus
rights I could not comprehend the
intense emotional turmoil a person
experiences when coping with gender
dysphoria until my own personal life
exposure as a mother and medical
professional I know how to advocate for
my family I ask questions I listen and I
trust I trust in both the practitioners
providing care for my family and I trust
in my children's words if my adolescent
is unable to live in a body that is not
the one they were biologically given at
16 years old I cannot comprehend how
that suddenly becomes a legal right at
18 most importantly I cannot fathom how
is it expected that their mental health
would support them to live through such
struggle to reach 18 our trans community
in New Hampshire will not survive the
loss of medical care that this law would
bring many transgender people die by
Suicide due to gender dysphoria they
experience and the extreme mental
anguish that our society's lack of
acceptance imposes every day it does not
have to be this way gender affirming
care is not only life-saving but is
life-giving hearing my teens say that
they are finally able to look at
themselves in the mirror and smile again
is just one example of the positive
impacts that has brought to their life
HB 1011 seeks to criminalize loving
supportive parents and families along
with compassionate providers it
tremendously increases the risk to
Providers within the granite state
providing gender affirming care to their
patients in need it would exacerbate the
isolation of trans gender adolescent
will be expected to persevere through
while awaiting the age of 18 to receive
the care they may desperately need to
survive and maybe the breaking point
they can no longer battle against please
1011 representative
Muse thank you for taking my question
um this legislature uh is or and has
been uh uh very concerned about the
rights of
parents
um speaking as a parent um do you feel
that this bill takes away your rights as
well as your child absolutely it does
thank
you see enough for the questions thank
you for coming and sharing your story
with us today thank you for
listening CH recognizes Nancy
Brennan
good morning and thank you for taking my
testimony I have been to a lot of
hearings over the years to a lot of
legislative sessions and I'm sure it
happens but this is the first time that
I haven't heard a bill presented before
you start taking testimony I'm sorry
that that didn't happen today because I
had questions about the bill that I was
hoping would be answered by the people
that sponsor it um I excuse me I'm on a
um while I believed what um
representative Canon had to say about uh
temporary uh hormone blockers I did some
research as as I do I am not a scientist
I'm a retired teacher and a New
Hampshire citizen but I did see where
some um studies show that hormone
blockers
might affect down the line um if
somebody decides to go back to being a
male I don't know if the jury is out on
that but I worry that that could be used
to keep kids from getting the chemicals
they need at 14 15 16 and I was hoping
that that would be talked about um today
and so I would suggest that the
committee get some of those answers
before you vote one of the things that
really bothered me was the idea that a
parent could be held liable for taking
their child across state lines to have
care done I don't know if you're aware
but there are kids all over this country
who are leaving the states they live in
and moving to other states specifically
because they can't get the care they
need and I believe it was in Texas where
a young man and his mother moved to New
Zealand he was 18 he had had some care
that was chemical care I don't know if
he'd had any surgery but he was about to
start college and they decided that if
they move to another state that state
might also stop him from getting the
hormones he needed and they needed to
leave this country less than 2% of our
population identifies as transgender and
there are so so many bills across this
country that that talk about
transgender
Youth and I'm sorry but some of the
testimony I hear some of the outrage I
hear from people like the man who has
the sandwich sign that says there are
only two genders I worry about our kids
I worry about the adults who are
transgender I worry about them worrying
about their own
safety I was lucky enough to work with
reny
Cushing for a couple of years to help
pass the trans gender non-discrimination
bill and I would hope that we understood
all the repercussions of that bill these
are human beings you may not have a
transgender person in your life I have
several and I would suggest that before
we pass any of these bills you listen to
people like the woman who spoke earlier
and you sit down with families because I
feel as though we are demonizing a
population and this is just one more
Bill to do this and I would I should
have brought water I'm so sorry but I
would like to say to the representative
that um commented on the fact that um
Dartmouth hiscock and some of these um
places that treat uh transgender youth
do do top and bottom surgery and she was
confused about whether they did it here
and it may have
come from a um last legislative session
there was a rep that got up and gave a
speech and read everything from the
Dartmouth Hitchcock site on transgender
care and used it to say that we were
doing surgery on kids what she didn't
read was the bottom line of that page
that said please note no surgery is done
to anyone under 18 years of age so you
really need to do your research before
you vote on these bills thank
you any
questions thank you thank you for your
Hawkins
good morning Mr chairman and committee I
appreciate the opportunity to testify
today my name is Sam Hawkins I'm the
public policy assistant at Nami New
Hampshire the National Alliance on
Mental Illness Nami New Hampshire is a
nonprofit Grassroots organization whose
mission is to improve the lives of all
people impacted by mental illness and
suicide on behalf of Nami New Hampshire
I'm here today to oppose HB 1011 it is
our interpretation that the bill intends
to uh criminalize uh puberty blockers
and hor hormone treatments as well so
that is a perspective in our testimony
uh but Nami New Hampshire believes that
all people should be treated with
respect and dignity and should have
access to mental and physical health
care free from interference largely due
to how they are mistreated and
stigmatized in society lgbtq plus
individuals especially those who are
transgender and non-binary are often at
an elevated risk for experiencing
anxiety and depression and are more
likely to consider an attempt suicide
than their heterosexual or cisgender
peers among several other tools and
interventions gender affirming
Healthcare is one important way we can
improve mental health outcomes for
transgender and non-binary youth
research shows that gender affirming
treatment including puberty blockers and
hormone treatment has a significant
association with lowered odds of
depression and
suicidality our Pol policies should
prioritize improving mental health
outcomes rather than restricting access
to care HB 1011 through CRI
criminalizing gender affirming
treatments including puberty blockers
and hormone treatments for an entire
segment of the youth population in our
state would eliminate access to vital
Services though directly better the
lives of transgender and non-binary
youth for these re reasons we urge the
committee to itl HB
1011 thank you um representative Manion
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um I might be
interpreting this bill different I've
I've heard a lot of testimony today
about these Pub blockers and hormone
therapy but not about the actual
surgeries so maybe I'm missing something
here but when I read this it says
physically or chemically removes or
Alters genitalia
I don't think in my opinion that isn't
the same as hormone blockers or hormone
therapy or puberty blockers Am I Wrong
can you explain the difference there we
interpreted the intent of the language
chemically Alters to wrap in puberty
blockers and hormone
treatments thank you for your question
thank
you thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um you mentioned um
the the risk of um uh suicidality and I
just wanted to you know we talk about
chemicals and and the way that that can
has a potential to be irreversible um so
my question is is is suicide reversible
thank you for your question suicide is
absolutely not reversible representative
please refrain from asking frivolous
questions any further
questions thank you for your testimony
thank
you um the chair recognizes Sydney lagu
I'm probably saying that wrong Leu it's
huh okay I didn't know if we're doing
not Hello um can you all hear me okay
I'm Sydney Leu and I'm from legendary
and I'm speaking for
myself on May 6th
1933 Nazi Germany raided The Institute
for sexual research in Berlin this was
just 4 months after Hitler was made
chancellor of Germany one of the first
things he did as
Chancellor The Institute for sexual
research in
Berlin existed as early as
199 and was created in
response to suicide and loss of life in
Community it was created by a medical
doctor
who was speaking to a patient who killed
himself after he could not
access medical care and his rights as a
human
being the institute for sexual research
in Berlin was
founded for as a function of Suicide
Prevention and it was one of the first
things that Nazi Germany went
after I went to public school in this
state
and as I'm sure you're aware we've all
seen pictures of Nazis burning books
from World War II the vast majority of
those photographs are destruction of
medical textbooks notes and research
institution I would also like to quote
the
bill this bill says quote it shall not
be a defense to prosecution that the
minor on whom it is performed or the
Minor's parent legal guardian consented
to the
procedure I'm having a very difficult
time understanding how a bill that says
the consent of the individual concerned
does not matter could possibly be about
the protection of children specifically
when this bill also excludes
circumcision as a quote accepted
practice
circumcision is typically performed at
consent and as you can
see gender affirming care has also can
practice and that's only from the one
example in Germany that's over a 100
years
old
this bill will harm
prevention regardless of your personal
opinion on the matter this is a greous
government overreach and sets a
dangerous precedent that New Hampshire
citizens cannot leave the
state and do what they believe is
correct for their individual selves and
families without not being able to
return home for fear of being criminally
charged that is a an incredibly
dangerous
precedent and it is not what our state
stands
for little um interactive question here
does anybody
know what the um latest data says about
the percentage of people who regret knee
Replacements this is a personal question
for me because my mom is currently
recovering from a knee replacement any
ideas on what percentage of patients who
get a knee replacement regret the
procedure ma'am the we don't take
questions but I'll take it as rhetorical
so go ahead sure thank you sir um most
data as published by the ni says it's
about
14% And I'll share a personal anecdote
obviously this is not data but um my
family and I have received lots of um
encouragement for my mom receiving her
procedure saying that it's great and it
will change your life and it the only
thing people tend to wish is that they
did it
earlier and that is for a procedure that
has a 14% rate of
regret gender affirming care
conservatively has a 1% rate of
regret most most data suggests it is
less than
1% I urge this committee to not use our
children and our children's
lives to further your political power or
whatever it is that you think this bill
is doing because any way you look at
it this bill does not protect children
at harms
children
questions
um thank you chair and thank you for
taking my question um I just want to
reiterate it's funny that you just
mentioned that because I was just doing
a little bit of research and yeah so
basically
0% of under 18 gender affirming care
have any regrets correct so I just
wanted to double down on that and I
wanted to reiterate what is question I
want to reiterate what my colleague had
just said is suicide reversible no ma'am
thank you representative please do not
ask frivolous childish questions we to
ask we are to ask the represent Su is
not frous it's an actual the question is
ridiculous it's not how is it ridiculous
when this bill will affect children
under do you not know that suicide is
not reversible did you not know that
before you came I just want to make sure
it's clear we ask questions I want to
make sure it's clear chairman she is my
constit I'm the constituent and I was
interested in her question thank you the
witness is excused thank you
next
70 and before we go on just to be clear
the reason that the sponsor did not come
is the sponsor asked us to itl this bill
so before we everyone gets excited um
anyway
uh good morning chairperson and thank
you for taking my testimony my name is
Emma savini I'm the children's
Behavioral Health policy coordinator at
new Futures new Futures is a nonpartisan
nonprofit health and wellness
organization um I'm here in strong
opposition to House Bill 1011 and I
understand you just mentioned that this
bill is set to be ited um and I'm
thankful for that but I would also just
note that there are several bills of
yes sorry thanks uh similar tone that um
I think my testimony would be helpful in
informing you on um I would like to just
underscore how dangerous bills like
these are to youth mental health um typ
uh specifically transgender youth mental
health um just in 2022 which is the most
recent data I could find 39% of lgbtq
Youth considered suicide and 55%
reported uh feeling depression and these
numbers um are specific to New Hampshire
and clearly indicate the dangerous
territory we are in with youth mental
health bills like these um contribute to
uh feelings of rejection and
discrimination in transgender Youth and
those feelings are tied to higher rates
of su suicidality self harm um isolation
post-traumatic stress disorder
incarceration
homelessness um and depression among
many other things early intervention and
treatment is critical to help reducing
those feel feelings of uh rejection and
uh discrimination and this can include
anything from those hormone replacement
therapies um therapeutic interventions
that representative Canon brought up and
um in very limited circumstances where
it's medically necessary transgender uh
I'm Excuse me um gender affirming
surgeries um when those medically
necessary treatments are administered to
youth um their rates of poor mental
health outcomes are on par with their um
cisgender counterparts so it's clear
from the data that these uh surgeries um
treatments and gender affirming Medical
Care is helping these this population of
Youth um for these reasons new future
strongly urges the committee to vote itl
on this bill um and I'm happy to take
any
noon thank you for Gathering today uh I
am Joseph noon uh one of the people as
seen in the New Hampshire Constitution
uh Bill of Rights notice that by
assuming the duties to become a public
trust officer it is your fiduciary duty
to protect the liberty and interest of
the People by accepting the office you
agree to become a trustee and agent of
the people as seen in New Hampshire
Constitution part one article 8 as it is
currently written the endangering the
welfare of a child statute has no
definition of the word endangering or
term this
wrong is this house bill 12 12
next it it'll be up next the next bill
um rep the chair recognizes Chris
echel
chel you to the committee thank you to
the committee my name is Chris urel I'm
an attorney with glad uh based in Boston
I'm a New Hampshire licensed attorney
and I am also um uh someone who
practices law in the area of access to
health care for transgender people um I
have extensive experience uh in
litigation and other areas of law
regarding access to healthare for
transgender people um I'd like to start
by pointing out that in 2018 this
legislature banned female genital
mutilation uh which is the basis for the
bill that we see here today I mean it's
the uh it's the preceding statute for
the bill that we see here today that was
uh enacted in response to an actual
problem involving a number not a large
number but a number of uh of young girls
in New Hampshire who had experienced
female genital mu mutilation connected
with ancestral ties to countries where
it's performed as a cultural norm this
bill does not address any such problem
and instead uses the dog whistle of
chemical castration which has become a
political term used to refer to the um
use of puberty blockers and hormone
therapy uh for for young people assigned
male at Birth uh to try to leverage the
same kind of concern about female GLE
mutilation and um apply it to other
children who experience gender dysphoria
I was hoping to hear from the sponsor
today because I wanted to hear directly
that this was the intent of the bill but
my inference is based on political usage
of the term nationally at this point in
time uh I'd like to take one moment to
note the sheer breadth of this bill
because uh in addition to the issues
around gender dysphoria treatment that
I've already mentioned uh this bill
would ostensibly ban chemotherapy for a
17-year-old with testicular cancer and
there is a safe haven for um for
surgical interventions that are
necessary to protect physical health but
those do not apply to uh to chemical
treatments such as
chemotherapy um so I just wanted to
point out that this bill is uh has has a
breath that is incomprehensible um but I
also just want to make the point to this
like legislature that while it is common
for uh for state legislatures to
regulate Medical Care and in fact it's
necessary for state legislators to take
on that role it is um unorthodox and
Incredibly incredibly inappropriate for
the legislature to Target one class of
vulnerable people for special regulation
of their access to Medical Care and
especially when it flies in the face of
established medical treatment that's
recognized by every single Major Medical
associ in the United
States I also want to note that uh in
this country right now we have seen a
number of states enact laws that block
access to health care for transgender
Youth and those laws exist in many
states and have been challenged in court
in many states and um among the states
that have seen Court challenges federal
judges have ruled that those uh those
laws are unconstitutional or likely
unconstitutional in eight states federal
judges have ruled that way and that
includes federal judges who are
appointed by conservative presidents
including Donald Trump um on the other
hand only one federal court has ruled
the opposite that a statute Banning
health care for transgender youth is uh
not
unconstitutional so it is extremely
likely that this statute if it were to
be enacted um and any other statute that
uh that uh prohibits healthcare for
transgender youth it's likely that that
would be found unconstitutional by a
court will note that there are appell at
federal courts that are uh deciding the
cases um in different ways and it's not
consistent across the board so I don't
mean to State overstate uh what courts
are saying but um I just want to flag
this issue because there are serious
constitutional concerns not only based
on the equal protection rights of
transgender people in the United States
but also on the constitutionally
protected rights for parents to direct
the upbringing of their children which
includes the right to to access um uh
well established medical care for their
children uh finally I just want to raise
one more point before opening up to
questions which is the role of the
legislature in terms of access to care
for individuals in New Hampshire it's
not the role of the legislature to
decide whether or not you believe as
individuals what is appropriate for
miners to receive in terms of healthare
the question before you is whether it's
appropriate for the legislature to
disregard medical standards of care and
block access to health care and uh with
that I will answer any questions that
anyone has thank you for your testimony
um isn't it true the Supreme Court just
turned away an appeal um of a case I
forget which state but the the Lower
Court ruled that um a law Banning care
was unconstitutional the state appealed
it and the and the Supreme Court turned
it away um I believe you're referring to
the Sketti case which arose out of
Tennessee and I um my latest information
was that the Supreme Court had not ruled
on whether or not they would hear I
think it was yesterday they turned it
away yesterday okay I didn't hear the
news but uh yeah thank you further
questions I representative
Muse thank you for taking my question in
this committee we hear a lot of people
on both sides of issues uh talk about
constitutional reasons to do or to not
do things in your opinion what are the
Constitutional problems specifically
with this bill the Constitutional
problems arise under the 14th Amendment
to the US Constitution which has you
know
multiple multiple Clauses that have um
you know multiple interpretations uh on
one hand there is the constitutionally
protected right to direct the upbringing
of one's children and that includes the
right to access medical care that your
children need if that Medical Care is
well established that is one area of
constitutional law that protects the
rights of um people to Access healthcare
uh another area is uh the right to equal
protection of the law when a law targets
one class of people for different
treatment the government looks at that
classification and determines whether or
not it is a suspect classification or
not a suspect classification determine
what level of scrutiny to apply when
reviewing the law when it's a sex-based
classification like the bill there's no
way to argue that this bill is not a
sex-based classification in fact it
explicitly targets uh targets targets
male uh people assign male at Birth and
uh additionally also um is going after
the type of care needed by transgender
people which is a sex-based
classification so by making a sex- based
classification uh there's heightened
scrutiny that's applied to uh the way
courts look at the law heightened
scrutiny would mean that there needs to
be an exceedingly persuasive
justification um and that there's not
more narrowly uh tailored options and
that's how the Constitution would apply
to review of a law like
this thank you for clarifying that
thanks for the question thank you for
your testimony I appreciate
Nafi good morning and thank you for
taking my testimony and I'll have a
answer for your question as well um my
name is Rabbi Robin Nafi I live in work
here in conquer I speak today on behalf
of myself as well as the members of the
Jewish clergy associ iation of New
Hampshire for a number of reasons we
oppose HB 1011 as we understand the
legislation section 1A would make it a
crime for any person to circumcise a
male a minor male and section 1B would
make it a crime for a parent to direct
another to circumcise a minor male with
the exception in both sections of the
accepted practice of circumcision of the
foreskin at Birth with parental consent
this exception appears to be included so
that the biblically commanded and
long-standing practice of circumcision
in the Jewish Community does not
suddenly become a
crime while we appreciate the effort the
language fails for several reasons first
the biblical commandment to circumcise
male babies specifies that it shall be
done on the eighth day not at Birth if
at Birth is supposed to include the eth
day of life the lack of specificity
makes the language of the proposed
legislation too vague to withstand
scrutiny second Jewish law requires that
the circumcision be delayed if medically
necessary for example the baby is born
premature has jaundice is of low body
weight or even has an eye infection
under these circumstances the
circumcision is to take place only when
a medical professional deems it safe to
do so this is often weeks or even months
after the birth extremely premature
babies for example are are often in the
Neo neonatal intensive care unit for
months after birth and their
circumcision might not happen until they
are six or eight months
old third some Jewish male babies are
not circumcised for many reasons
including parental Choice those parents
may change their mind the child as he
grows up may want to be circumcised or
the child may need to be circumcised
before undertaking the Jewish right of
passage into Jewish adulthood called Bar
Mitzvah not of these would occur at
Birth fourth Jewish clergy are
occasionally approached by families
consisting of parents with their minor
children who wish to convert to Judaism
together or by older minors who wish to
convert and have their parents consent
in most denominations of judaism's male
both male males minors and adults would
need to become circumcised rarely are
the minors in these situations
newborns furthermore if the males are
already circumcised when they seek to
convert Judaism requires a procedure
called hatat the spilling of a drop of
blood which takes place just here
whether this little known procedure
would be covered by the bill as it is
circumcision as I indicated I would
answer uh me also mention uh another
constitutional concern with this and
that obviously is the free exercise of
religion as as protected in the First
Amendment and for all of these reasons
the Jewish clergy Association of New
Hampshire must oppose
hb101 I'm going to add add address what
we understand to be the true intent of
this bill to ban gender affirming
surgery to transgender youth when
focusing on just this aspect of the bill
the Jewish clergy Association of New
Hampshire still opposes the legislation
in Genesis chapter 1 the creation of
humanity is called Bellum Elohim in the
image of God we believe that all genders
are created as such the highest
commandment or Mitzvah and Judaism that
one can undertake is Pak nees or saving
a life this commandment is so important
that we must break other Jewish laws in
order to fulfill it an Orthodox Jewish
physician who does not drive on the
Sabbath would be required to do so in
order to perform a life-saving medical
procedure a person who is starving must
eat non kosher food such as pork in
order to save their own life if no
Kosher food is available the examples
are endless studies show as has been
heard before that gender
dysphoria can be significant in youth
especially gender dysphoria can be so
intense as to lead to depression and
anxiety and have a negative impact on
daily life it can also lead to Suicide
suicide attempts and suicidal
ideation many Studies have shown that
somewhere around 40% of lgbtq young
people seriously consider
suicide any bill that would deny access
to these potentially life-saving medical
procedures violates the principle of Pak
nees saving a life and thus the Jewish
clergy Association of New Hampshire must
oppose 10-11 on this ground as well it
must be noted that while not all
denominations or individuals within the
Jewish Community share our position the
members of the Jewish clergy associ
ation who do hold this position are
broadly representative of Jews
affiliated with the reform conservative
and Reconstructionist movements that
make up roughly 75% of American
synagogue Affiliated Jews thank you for
taking my testimony I have spoken this
morning on behalf of myself and Rabbi
Dan arenson of Keane Rabbi Beth G
Davidson of Manchester caner Marilyn
Ferman of Bartlet Rabbi Jan Katz of
lonia Rabbi Donna kbam of Bethlehem
rabbi Peter Levy of dairy caner Amy
brener mitz of Sugar Hill caner shirinov
she have conquered Rabbi Mark Philipe of
Manchester Rabbi Joshua seagull of
Bennington caner Wendy Sherman of
Guilford Rabbi Jonathan spir ofet of
Nashua Rabbi Kai Stern s Kaufman of
Portsmouth and other members of the of
the association who did not have time to
get authorization to sign this from
their
stakeholders thank
you thank you um you brought up an
interesting point it does it not also
sometimes occur that a circumcision even
if it's done right at Birth needs
correction later
on rarely but but occasionally yes it
does so that would be an an yeah those
are usually actually Hospital
circumcisions circumcisions are the one
that take place at Birth right we have
it done by somebody who is both ritually
and medically trained mostly doctors but
not exclusively um doing it at the eth
day thank you further questions for the
rabbi seeing none thank you for your
you Anthony Tanner the chair recognizes
Anthony
Tanner oh it is I'm sorry
yeah she wave it okay is there anyone
wishing to testify on this spill hasn't
testified
yet seeing none I'm going to close the
public hearing if anyone's interested to
stay we're going to exec this bill in
about five
minutes five minute break Republicans
office can you text him and ask him why
that
done okay I'm um what's in that bill
number I'm opening the executive session
on on uh HP
1011 and I am making a motion of an
expedience to legisl can have a second
I'll second a motion seconded by
representative Gite I'll speak to my
motion um couple things first some
people are wondering why we heard the
bill because the sponsor didn't show up
um by by the Constitution we have to
hear every Bill regardless if they show
up or not second of all um based on
testimony we heard based on bills that
have previously passed there's
absolutely no reason for this bill and
um I think we should kill it represent G
right with speak to your motion um I
think you did a great job I will mention
that um I appreciate the fact that um
Rabbi ran was here and gave testimony as
well yeah I agree um that was very very
enlightening um with regard to the the
postbirth date I I suspect it as much
but she confirmed it any further
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role the motion is
inexpedient to legislate representative
oh representative scitec yes
representative PR yes representative
jandrin not here representative Manion
yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
tenar yes representative gther yes
representative Muse yes representative
rang yes representative Bradley yes
represent representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative wheeler yay chairman Roy
chair votes yes motion is unanimous any
objection to consent seeing none the
bill will go on consent as inexpedient
to legislate I close the executive
session Mr chairman if I could please
just have the the number so I could what
is the vot
total
yeah I didn't know how many people
weren't
here
177 uh hereby open the executive uh
excuse me the public hearing on HP 1012
and recognize the prime sponsored Inu
the
bill
notepad
morning Mr chairman and members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Leah kushman I the prime sponsor of HB
1012 and I represent the town of
we so um if you've read the bill maybe
looked into similar legislation that has
passed in other states
um there's been several bills like this
uh that have passed in a bipartisan
manner in other states including Texas
Oklahoma Colorado Utah and
Connecticut um this bill protects
parents rights to make parenting
decisions while also protecting the
ability of children to grow into
Independence um other state laws that
were just passed about this dealt with
how neglect is defined and I think
that's good um our laws are a little
different um you know parents were being
charged with neglect for uh letting
their kids walk to school
for um having their kids home learning
remotely while they went to work even
though they were forced to have that
happen um for using farm
equipment um or letting their kids use
farm equipment or
lawnmowers um so but this bill addresses
another serious charge in our state
which is endangering the welfare of a
child and in our state it's this law
that's being used to turn parents into
criminals we need to clarify this law
right now the broadness of the statute
is allowing zealous prosecutors to
decide what child endangerment is while
leaving the waters muddied for
parents I know of a dad he's my
constituent um who let his teen daughter
carry a concealed pistol While She Was
Out on a walk and he was charged under
this
section his daughter was proficient with
Firearms she'd been using them since a
very young age there were reports of
coyotes in the area and a neighbor had
recently been attacked by a raccoon she
enjoyed a morning walk um but she wanted
to feel protected and being Adept in the
use safe use of a firearm her dad
allowed her to carry it conce FAL
nothing happened but unfortunately the
parents are divorced the mother later
found out and
disagreed and reported it and the father
was then charged with four counts of
endangering the welfare of a child which
was then all the charges were
dropped um we don't have any laws in
this state that prohibit um miners from
protecting themselves
and um but it it it's just an example of
of the law being open for interpretation
for
prosecutors um to use against parents
for things that the legislature has not
declared to be crimes and it puts
prosecution prosecutors in the position
of making the law when we don't say what
we
mean um right now this La the current
law RSA 639 col 3 says um in uh part one
knowingly in
danger um is is one of the words that is
used there so there must be zero risk in
the parenting
decision um purposely it says
purposefully violating a duty of care
protection or support or inducing a
child to engage in conduct conduct that
endangers their health or safety this is
subjective if a prosecutor can use this
law to interfere with the constitutional
right to self-defense they can use it to
Target what Target whatever kind of
parenting they don't don't like and just
because you're not in your parenting
style and beliefs and values aren't in
the crosshairs right now it doesn't mean
that they can't be in the future if we
don't correct this
language um prosecutors are not parents
and they're not law makers they all have
parents all have different values
beliefs everyone assesses risk
differently and different parents can
look at the same statistical risk even
and interpret it as high or low and
it'll be different from another parent's
assessment of that risk based on their
values knowledge and beliefs so say as a
parent you decide to put a mask on your
kids right that's been shown to show to
have negative health effects you could
be charged under the right
prosecutor um if you let your older kids
babysit your younger kids you could be
charged keep your kids home for remote
learning while you're at work give your
kids life-saving medication or vaccine
that a prosecutor disapproves of let
your child walk to school it's risky
definitely not zero risk they could get
hit by a car you could be charged under
this
section um have a home birth maybe let
your child sit alone in a car it used to
be very common for even small children
to be alone in the car and was
considered safe things are changing now
and some states have laws on this but
our state does not so a parent could
look and say oh New Hampshire doesn't
have a law on this so I'm I'm clear to
make my own decision and then a
prosecutor can come along and
arbitrarily decide what age how long and
under what
circumstances that that's okay and when
it's not and that's our job that's not
Prosecutor's job if we want to make that
illegal we need to put in a bill and
make it illegal
specifically
um the maxims of law say it is a
wretched state of slavery which subsists
where the law is vague or
uncertain pretty serious another Maxim
says an act of legislature to have force
of law must must be intelligibly
expressed and when too vague is a
nullity so you can see there's probably
some issues with even Prosecuting these
when the law is vague if we think
certain parenting decisions should be
criminalized we need to spell them out
go through the full legislative process
so the inalienable rights of parents to
direct the upbringing of their children
can be weighed against an action with
due debate and recurrence to the
Constitution for guidance because that's
what we do like the previous bill so
that's why the bill has certain elements
to describe a parenting decision that's
the right of the parents to make and
exempting those from guilt and therefore
reducing frivolous prosecution the
courts can rule and set precedent but
we've seen that doesn't stop zealous
prosecutors or even entities in the
private realm from continuing to violate
people's rights so we can't just leave
this statute the way it is so people
find themselves blindsided fighting for
their rights in court when they never
should have been a
charge um I'm not married to the
language um I'm happy to work with
anyone on amendments if we want to find
tunit criminal code is not my usual
statutes that I work in so I know there
are different um nor normative um terms
and and structure and things like that
so I'm really happy and and would hope
that someone would reach out to me so I
can work on the language if there's any
issues um but every every decision in
parenting has some level of risk um so
if a parent can Dem can demonstrate that
all four of the elements that I require
in the bill um
then they can't be found guilty under
under the language of this bill so a if
there's no actual harm or if there is
harm by some unforeseen circumstance so
that would be like walking to sto school
and getting hit by a car I don't believe
that that should be a criminal charge um
for letting your kid walk to school um B
if we want it to be illegal let's name
the crime let's describe it so parents
can know the ground rules let's weigh
the constitutionality of it in
legislative proceedings if the
legislature didn't name it and there are
some crimes described in this statute
specifically um such as branding a child
or soliciting a minor of SE for sex we
can name them let's name them we'll add
them here uh the parent see is the
parents can attest to the fact that they
made the decision consciously in weigh
benefit versus risk and D the parent can
attest that the decision is in line with
their family values and make sense as a
decision for their family these are just
elements of making a parenting decision
that show that
you know you were conscious about it and
maybe your risk assessment was different
from someone else's but there was no
harm um there's a freerange child
movement growing as a result of research
on anxiety in children so there's a lot
of support for bills like this and
that's where a lot of the support um
came from in other states our research
is showing that kids who haven't had
more opportunities for Independence and
independent activities um have higher
levels of
anxiety and more social emotional
problems so there's lots of research on
that too which I'd be happy to get for
the committee and I'd be happy to take
any questions thank
you questions for the
sponsor represent
M do you believe that Society has a
fairly broad interest in protecting the
children uh societ
as a whole I think that government has
an interest of protecting the
constitutional rights of all people um
and if they're being violated that we
certainly have an interest to step in
and put some guard rails in place on how
to handle that absolutely followup
please follow up I I didn't ask about
their constitutional rights I asked
lives um I think no one has more
interest in the lives of children than
their parents
thank
you further
she chair calls um now we call
noon I kind of like that bill
uh hello I am Joseph noon one of the
people as seen in the New Hampshire
Constitution Bill of
Rights uh take notice that by assuming
the duties to become a public trust
officer it is your fiduciary duty to
protect the Liberty interests of the
People by accepting this office you
agree to become a trustee and agent of
the people as seen in New Hampshire
Constitution part one article 8 as it is
currently written the endangering the
welfare of a child statute has no
definition of the word endangering or
the term duty of care therefore this
statute is null and void for
vagueness uh so maxims of law where
there where law is uncertain there is no
law blacks 8 uh 1181 and bouier 160
maximum of law an act of legislature to
have a force of law must intelligibly
Express and when to vague is nullity
Larin versus consolid a Consolidated
Telegraph
maximum of law it is a miserable state
of things where the law is vague and
uncertain bouier
155 that being said I in favor of this
house bill 1012 as the purpose for
government is to protect the life
liberty and property of the
people uh I've done a lot of research on
the child protective service industrial
complex
lately uh there is a clear pattern of
abuse
of the current endangering the welfare
charge being used by New Hampshire DCF
and Child Protection Services in all
states as a retaliation against parents
who reject the Services of New Hampshire
DCF in cases where no harm or injury has
incurred to a child or an
incompetent this same same statute has
been applied against a father who is a
friend of mine for allowing his teenage
daughter to carry a sidearm while out
hiking there was no injury or harm this
father also declined the Services of New
Hampshire
DCF the charges were dropped uh this guy
is in the process of suing the state of
New Hampshire over this
situation uh this same act has been used
against Farm families for allowing kids
to do farm chores operate farm equipment
uh homeschoolers unvaccinated families
and political opponents of whoever is in
the position of power to bring this
charge against the people and I will
warn you if and when the pendulum swings
hard to the right this same statute can
be used against political opponents of
the
right take notice not passing this Bill
H HB 1012 will result in continued
liabilities against the state of New
Hampshire which we all know just comes
out of the pockets of of the
taxpayers take notice the current
language of this statute just puts a lot
of unnecessary
litigation in the court systems as the
judicial courts can only adjud cases
where someone's legal rights have been
damage the appeals court Andor Supreme
Courts are often hearing cases where
State prosecutors cannot prove any
evidence of someone's rights being
violated resulting in a verdict being
overturned to quote the US Supreme Court
and Tyler versus judges of the court of
registration the duty of the Court as of
every judicial tribunal is limited to
determining rights of persons or
property which are actually controverted
in a particular case before
it please take notice of the fact of the
current
endangerment uh endangering the tri
welfare of a child statute is totally
unconstitutional if said statute is
charged against someone where no injury
or harm has occurred as there is no
constitutional authority to charge a man
or a woman with a crime that could
result in jail time without their first
being an injured party passing this bill
is a corrective action to fix a current
statute that is in conflict with the
Constitution not passing this bill will
continue to cause the people of New
Hampshire irreparable harm and damage uh
directly in the form of uh parents being
wrongfully charged
and indirectly in the form of the
division of risk and benefit settling
claims against the state of New
Hampshire for constitutional rights
violations that arise out of people
being charged with the endangering the
welfare of a child statute where no
injury or harm has taken
place if you oppose this bill then I
have a question for you to ask yourself
where is the Constitutional authority to
bring a charge against one of the people
that could result in up to a year in
prison where there is not even a claim
of someone's rights being
violated thank you and I will take a
question if anybody has
one questions for the
witness see none thank you for your
testimony this
morning um okay hold on SEC attorney
Enders would you be willing to let us
pick your brain after everyone else
testifies on this Bill thank
you
nardy so uh had an intended to testify
so I'll keep this very uh brief uh it
appears that there's a problem uh
currently in the
legislation where the line is not known
into what is potentially endangering
behavior and is not
and that line is being decided on an ad
hoc basis Case by Case by a bureaucrat
who is unaccountable to the people at
the moment it occurs which is going
along it appears political lines this is
extremely dangerous the state house
needs to come up with a solution to this
so that parents will know what is
allowed and what is not allowed that
cannot be allowed to be made up on the
spot
by whoever happens to be there at that
time because the penalties for being on
the wrong side of that line are dire and
putting a a parent in prison for a year
is not going to help the welfare of that
child it's going to make it worse so
this is a big opportunity for government
to actually do something to help make
things better as opposed to just
complicating and making the problem
worse so I mean I guess I could take a
question seeing none thank you for your
testimony this morning thank you ladies
and
gentlemen the chair recognizes Michael
korski
korski I should not do better on polish
can't Michael karki currently live in
hookit uh moved to New Hampshire a
little bit more than four years ago I
came to this country in 1990 from what
was still then Soviet
Union uh one of the big problems in
Soviet Union was
that uh risk and uncertainty is uh
integral part of life you cannot avoid
it and when legislation is
unclear and decide decision what risks
are acceptable what actually acceptable
are not clear it becomes arbitrary so in
Soviet Union more in terms of production
you know people who were administering
Enterprises and so on uh in order to
work in order to produce to do the plan
you have to violate the law you cannot
do it otherwise so ever was a criminal
and everybody could be prosecuted at any
point or fired for not doing the
plan which is basically not not a
society you would want to live in there
it only was concerned of people who
production but for normal people there
were no such thing as politics people
were not in politics I did not know the
you know 50s the St time I was growing
in 1970s 80s which was you know kind of
brf's slow going you you keep silent
nobody would touch you and uh I know for
sure that people in America parents in
America live in much greater fear of
State than people in Soviet Union in
1980s and '90s and 70s probably because
the risks that were normal for
Generations the RIS that were know
acceptable few years ago suddenly
decided out of bounds and uh you could
get serious even if you get acquitted
you spend years and months you
get deprived from the right to see your
children you have to live separately you
have to spend Fortune to do something
that was considered normal years
ago and it's it's based on unclear
basically laws that doesn't specify the
boundaries and uh if we keep going this
way it will end up probably worse than
in Soviet Union because we have more
complexity there here than there and
uh
basically if law doesn't specify it it's
better to ER on the initiative of the
people or of the parents because if
people cannot judge their risks
themselves then how is democracy
supposed to work how it supposed to
elect someone who is supposed to do that
for
them so if the law is not clear it's
better to air on the side of initiative
and Liberty of the people then on safety
and removal of risk which is impossible
thank
Smith hello I'm Mary Smith uh of
Manchester New Hampshire I'm here to
bill um thank you for your attention
chair
others this bill as the previous
testimony that you heard
addresses a matter of vaguery that
currently exists in the
rsas um this has been adjudicated by the
Supreme Court in New
Hampshire um in a bunch of different
cases um but as part of my testimony I
wanted to quote to you one case State V
bortner in
2004 that outlines why the Supreme Court
had not thrown this out on the grounds
that it is uh too vague could you repeat
the last name State V what a state V
bortner that is b o r t n r
2004 so in the uh in their opinion the
said uh contrary to the defendants
argument that the two men's rehea in
statute are in irreconcilable or
incompatible there are numerous ways in
which a person can purposely Act fail to
act without knowing it will endanger the
welfare of a child for example a parent
who fails to seek medical attention for
a child who sprains a finger may have
purposely violated a duty of care and
that that's an important just a part of
the Crux of this is the definition and
the understanding of what constitutes a
duty of care so back to the um uh the
Supreme Court
um a parent who fails to seek medical
attention for a child who sprains a
finger may have purposely violated a
duty of care that that parent owes to
the child but since a sprained finger is
unlikely to cause death or Serious
injury it is possible that the parent
did not knowingly endanger the welfare
of the child on the other hand a parent
who fails to promptly seek medical
attention for a child child who stops
breathing may have purposely violated a
duty of care in addition the parent may
have knowingly endangered the welfare of
a child due to the high risk of death or
Serious injury that is likely to result
these examples demonstrate that the two
separate men's Rea of knowingly and
purposely are not necessarily
irreconcilable or incompatible we thus
clude that the statute is sufficiently
clear to warn the average person of the
prohibited conduct and that the
coexistence of the purposely and
knowingly is does not render the statute
impermissibly
vague so that's just a section of that
um and I just like to point out that uh
if the law if as the prosecutors are uh
pursuing it
um was
as the uh Supreme Court of New Hampshire
defined here in this case uh
then I don't think I would be as
motivated or many others would be as
motivated to talk to this bill
today um but we are here today because
that's not how the law is currently
being applied to parents across the
state of New Hampshire where there are
plenty of behaviors that are nowhere
close to a high risk of death or Serious
injury or a medium risk of death or
Serious injury or a moderately low risk
of serious death or injury where they
are being charged by prosecutors for
conduct that is is otherwise like less
risky than driving their children to a
location I mean driving is one of the
the most dangerous activities we engage
in on a regular basis and some of these
behaviors that parents are being
prosecuted for uh under this statute
unchanged are not even close to
dangerous in the way that driving on the
public roadways is and the risks that
that carries so um that's why I'm in
support of this bill I mean it's it's
clear it moves the the standard from
duty of care to actual harm or injury
with additional uh criteria it's not
just that it also includes that the
parents would also H or Guardians would
have to
articulate um like a a reasoning as to
the risk or benefit of allowing the
children to do whatever the behavior was
or the conduct they engaged in so I I
really encourage you if you have any uh
problems uh with this for which you
don't think uh I would be good to answer
your questions please instead of voting
to um itl this bill or recommending to
itl the bill please consider working
with
representative um kushman on it for
whatever you think the issue is because
this this needs to be cleared up so
maybe if you don't like the language or
you want to see it uh clarified in some
way I I encourage you to work with her
but I like the language as it is uh I'm
willing to take any
questions thank you um do you have any
examples of um you said that it's being
used to prosecute any further examples
than what we've already
heard uh I think the examples you've
already heard
are uh pretty clear um I actually didn't
know about the one of uh I guess a
father recently who had this uh issue
where he thought it would be the prudent
thing to do to give his his daughter a
um a firearm for her walk out um I don't
know I wasn't in those circumstances I
can't speak to that um I'm aware of many
cases
of uh parents
whose
um their custody of their children has
been threatened because of leaving their
children in the car for example when
they go into the store um from my
personal experience when I looked at the
any data I I could whatever data was
available on how many children have died
uh because of heat stroke or anything
related to being left in the car when a
parent goes to uh the store because I
don't know maybe the kid's sleeping or
something like that um I could not find
a single case there there are um in New
Hampshire
of a child
dying um and this is not because of the
laws we have there there are other
states that have laws explicitly against
this Behavior and the numbers of child
deaths are higher in those States um so
it was over the past 50 years I couldn't
find a single example just just for that
behavior um that parents are being
prosecuted over and and bring being
brought to court over um so there's also
the question of allowing your children
to um walk to the store by themselves or
walk to school by themselves that
unfortunately
parents are being prosecuted over here
in New Hampshire so um do you have any
other
questions
representative Murray thank you Mr chair
um I was just curious if you could share
with the committee under what
circumstances do you think it is
appropriate for the state to intervene
circumstances outlined in representative
kushman's Bill are pretty
good
where it isn't just that actual harm har
or injury has occurred but also that
parents are unable to articulate any
sort of reason cost benefit or that it
is in in alignment with their values so
it could be the case that um there was a
behavior that could have caused a lot of
harm to the
children but didn't
luckily that would not uh pass the
scrutiny of the criteria in
representative kushman's bill because
when the parents are asked the parents
give lousy
reasons or reasons that don't indicate
that there was any sort of cost benefit
analysis done of the uh safety of the
Behavior Uh versus the risks that it
posed so uh that is an excellent
question and that is one that is
addressed directly by representative
kushman's
um
Bill thank you uh no further questions
7y good morning again my name is msv I'm
the children's Behavior Health policy
coordinator at new futures um I signed
in opposition to this bill um I just I
just spoke spoke with representative
kushman about my concerns about the
language um and hopefully we'll work
something out with her so I don't feel
that my testimony that I had planned was
necessary at this point so at this point
new Futures has no position on the bill
um as the bill stands it we are opposed
to it okay but representative wheeler
has a quick question what was your
objection to the language thank you Mr
chairman um
just uh we are in support of any bill
that is uh using evidence-based
practices for for reducing um poor
mental health outcomes for children um
and so I just think there is a maybe
more appropriate space in our state
legis legislation um that would would be
able to accomplish that the goal of
Representative kushman um as it pertains
to the Freer range kids movement um that
may not open up the child endangerment
statute thank
you uh no not so quick uh representative
Muse um
I'm sorry I did not catch your name or
your organization sorry my name is Emma
savini and I am with new Futures with
new Futures thank you quick go thank you
Enders attorney Enders you have the bad
luck of being in the wrong place at the
right time
um I know you did not and do not have a
position on the bill however um the
chair and the committee would like to
Avail ourselves of your
expertise Could you um give us two
things could you tell us how often you
see this prosecuted m in your particular
uh court and what if any opinion you
have on how this were this to become
law if it would cause problems or
not thank you for the record my name is
Steven Andis I'm an attorney at the
marac County Attorney's Office I'm an
assistant County attorney I've been a
prosecutor for over 20 years now um with
reference to how often we see this
charge certainly as a circuit court
misdemeanor prosecutor I saw
it I don't want to say often but we
certainly did see endangering the
welfare of minor
charges
um I when I think about sort of criminal
law and law in general Behavior really
exists on a spectrum and on one side of
that Spectrum you have sort of Ideal
behavior that we all strive to to
emulate you have sort of the the perfect
person and then next to the perfect
person you have you know acceptable
behavior encouraged Behavior you
have um maybe not encouraged Behavior
but behavior that is societally
acceptable and I always think think in
terms of examples like going out for a
drink after work with your co-workers
maybe isn't necessarily societally
encouraged Behavior but is acceptable in
our society then you have behavior that
is is frowned upon in our society and
the example I always give is if you're
Seated on a Subway or or something like
that and a a pregnant woman comes on our
society encourages you to give up your
seat to to the pregnant woman that's and
if you don't that's sort of frowned
upon then further over we have you know
unacceptable
behavior um Behavior where you're going
to get sued perhaps civil and then
further over there's this line somewhere
where that behavior becomes criminal and
then in the criminal side you have class
A misdemeanors Class B misdemeanors and
felonies so what's hard is that conduct
really
exists on that
Spectrum in it depends on where you are
in terms of societal norms and it also
depends on when you're living in
history and the endangering the welfare
of a minor statute I think really points
points that out that my understanding is
that there are countries in the world
where people leave their children home
alone and go out to dinner and that's
the norm my understanding is there's
countries in the world where you know
people leave children in baby carriages
in front of the store and go in and
that's the norm that's not necessarily
acceptable
here and it also as I was saying depends
on when you are in history in terms of I
know that you know I grew up in a time
when we only had lap belts in the car
and helmets were sort of unknown to us
and that's just was acceptable at the
time whereas now that would be frowned
upon or maybe even cross into that
criminal world so I think it's hard when
you look at the behavior of parents
regarding their children to sort of
figure out am I looking at bad parenting
or am I looking at criminal behavior in
violation of the endangering the welfare
of a minor statute and for me when I
look at this statute it it does use the
term purposely violating a duty of care
protection or
support and purposely is defined in RSA
as
um a person acts purposely with respect
to a material element in offense when
his conscious object is to cause the
result or engage in the conduct that
comprises the
element
so in my opinion to violate the
endangering welfare of a child statute
your purpose your conscious object has
to be to violate the duty of care you
and where we've seen this occur and
where we've prosecuted it in the past is
we've had individuals who are driving
drunk with their kids in the
car you you know you have a duty of care
to your children and when you put them
in the car and you're intoxicated and
you're driving you're purposely
violating that duty of care so I do
think that in those circumstances and
endangering the welfare of a child
charge
is
appropriate we've also seen it where um
we had a person who was using drugs and
um tried to cook something I don't
remember what it was but essentially set
her house on fire and passed out um from
a drug overdose with her children in the
house we charged that individual with
endangering the welfare of a minor
because we felt that she purposely
violated duty to care to her
child uh we have a case that I believe
is pending now where a woman hid her
children in the closet and were alleging
that she then set her house on fire um
when the fire department showed up she
didn't mention anything about having
children in the house the firefighters
actually found the the children hiding
in the in in the house um we charged her
with endangering the welfare of a minor
because again we felt that was an
appropriate
charge I have also um charged people for
leaving children in cars and I can think
of a case I had where an individual who
was not from New Hampshire was visiting
New Hampshire because his father was was
dying in uh was in hospice and I believe
hookit was staying in a hotel in conquer
with a uh I think it was an
eight-year-old son and when his father
passed away in the middle of the night
he left to go to to hookit to check on
things I don't know if you didn't
realize how far hookit was from
conquered but left his eight-year-old
child alone in a hotel room uh for at
unfortunately several
hours
um we did charge him with endangering
the welfare of a
minor the other sort of piece to this
though
is the resolution of these cases
between a person well in someone had
brought up the example of your child
sprains their finger and
essentially um whether you seek medical
care for your child with a sprain finger
I I think the answer to that one
unfortunately is it depends when you
look at
6393 subsection five it talks
about um I'm sorry subsection four
it talks about a person who pursuant to
the tenants of a recognized religion
fails to conform to an otherwise
existing duty of care is not guilty of
an offense under this section so if
you're not seeking medical care because
you're part of an organized religion
that doesn't seek medical care for
sprained fingers you're not guilty of a
crime under this section if you're not
seeking medical care because you know
you want to watch the Food Network and
you've got better things to do than take
your child to the emergency room I I
think you could potentially face charges
under this
section
but as a prosecutor when we're getting
endangering the welfare of a child
charges it it's always sort of been my
opinion that
there's parents aren't generally trying
to hurt their children I mean we've
certainly had cases where parents are
affirmatively trying to hurt their
children and they should be sentenced
appropriately but a lot of the cases
that we get where it's you know if a
parent's leaving a child in a room alone
um leaving the child in a car it's not
necessarily that they're trying to hurt
the child it's that they don't know any
better and I think charging someone with
endangering the welfare of a minor may
be a wakeup call certainly I've
referred cases I want to say the
individual in the hotel room who left
his child alone my recollection in that
case is that we resolved it by referring
him to do a parenting class through a
diversion program because I don't think
he's trying to hurt his kid I think he
just didn't know any better that he
shouldn't leave his kid in the hotel
room so I think sentencing does come
into that
um I don't know if that answers it was
very helpful thank you generally um if
you could uh have there been referrals
you see have received from perhaps from
DCF that you declin to
prosecute so as a prosecutor we received
cases from the police departments um
we're not out actively you know
investigating crime necessarily we're
sitting behind our desk and we wait for
the police to come drop the case on the
desk and say prosecute this
so we wouldn't necessarily receive
criminal complaints from DCF normally
DCF would notify the police department
and the police Department would do an
investigation um we may get the the case
from the police department whenever
there's a child involved the police
department and DCF work together
initially so it it wouldn't be uncommon
for the police to notify dcyf or DCF to
notify the
police and generally speaking if a
charge is brought by the police you do
bring you do more forward with
charges generally generally yes yes
certainly I can say for me personally
especially with endangering Weare of a
minor I've always taken sort of a
critical look at those cases because I
do think
there's a gray area where there's bad
parenting and then there's a line where
that bad parenting becomes criminal
conduct
and I always sort of want to make sure
I'm in the criminal conduct line of that
gray
area
um I'm going to I'm going to allow
questions um generally speaking he he um
kind of got trapped into this so let's
keep the
questions non-confrontational as
possible I was going to say you can
throw me hard questions it's fine you
all right represent uh
seig thank you so much and thank you for
taking my question
um if I may uh give a hypothetical an
Ask word that would fall on under this
proposed legislation um just so that I
can have a greater understanding so I I
have a 16-year-old and you know
sometimes we headbutt as is not uncommon
with 16y olds and their their mothers um
so if I believed as a system of
discipline that the appropriate thing to
do would be to lock her in her bedroom
for 4 days with a bucket for waste and
um you know a couple bottles of water um
but because I believe that was going to
help teach her the discipline necessary
to not speak to me the way she did or
behave the way she did and I I truly
believe that that is my parenting
decision intended to encourage their
independence and freedom um where where
would you view that under so and if I
did that regularly um how would that
this I do know that the New Hampshire
Supreme Court recently came out with a
case I don't know the name of it off the
top of my head but it involved a parent
locking a child in a room or they were
locked from the outside so the child
couldn't leave the room um there were no
bathroom facilities in the room and the
Supreme Court did find that that was
endangering the welfare of a minor part
of the reason they found that was
because the parent was unavailable
should there be an emergency since it
was locked from the outside the kid
I would have to look at the facts of
what you're doing in in for me
personally the first thing I would do if
I was handed that case would be to
reread the Supreme Court case and see
exactly why they felt the way they
did I would also be concerned in your
situation about the child's access to
essentially being able to get out if
there was in fact an
emergency if your system of Parental
discipline is to lock the child in the
room for 4 days and you have some good
faith you know basis for doing that and
that's your your parenting
style I don't know that that crosses the
line too endangering for me as long as
there were safeguards in place where if
there was an emergency the child could
communicate with you could get out of
thing representative Stone thank you
thank you for my question uh one of the
current languages this bills that's
being proposed do you find it to be a
huge hindrance in prosecution from your
your
perspective part of the language of the
current bill that that I'm I wouldn't be
in favor of is the the first line about
there is no actual injury or harm or any
actual injury or harm is the result of
unavoidable or unforeseeable accident
and the reason I would have a problem
with that is to me that's sort of the no
harm no foul language and the difficulty
with that is when you're talking about
children and risking injury to a
child I think I'd rather see law
enforcement be proactive than reactive
I'd rather see a child in a situation
where perhaps they could get hurt having
law enforcement intervene before the
child gets hurt to say we're going to
stop this rather than waiting for the
child to get hurt and then saying well
we you shouldn't have done this to begin
with so I I don't like the language in
uh in paragraph
a the rest of the language I don't
necessarily have an an objection to for
me personally and again I think it it
almost mirrors the current Statute in
terms of there's a uh an exception for
conforming to an organized religion and
I think saying a
a parenting
decision is is almost akin to me to an
organized religion if you have sort of
an
intelligent backing up of that parenting
you thank you for your time yeah thank
you any further Witnesses who haven't
testified who wish to testify on the
where oh you should have asked just go
ask opening the public hearing on House
Bill 1017 invite the sponsor to come
bill
good morning Mr chair members of the
committee uh for the record
representative Mike Belcher Carol County
4 weak field uh I have the pleasure here
this is my first time I believe before
this committee um so I'd like to
recommend my bill that does several
things regarding uh sheriffs in this
state their uh their abilities their
Authority and their responsibilities um
first thing I've done is that I have
brought in language that exists
elsewhere in New Hampshire law that
provides Mayors with the authority to in
an emergent basis
um deputi or whatever the proper
language is there to bring in persons in
an official capacity to put down breach
of the piece if it were to be
necessary uh I believe that as the
highest law enforcement official in the
county that sheriffs should also have
that same capacity um that Mayors
do in order to affect that change and
make it not conflict with certain laws
regarding
Deputy sheriffs I have modified some
language in minor ways and added a new
section that breaks out Deputy sheriffs
into two distinct categories currently
Deputy sheriffs under law exist
primarily for the service of process
they're compensated under under special
uh guidelines and that's all retained
under this bill uh it then breaks out a
second category of special Deputy that
would be this again on an emerging basis
in order to put down breaches of the
piece something that could be done
immediately uh without significant
see the third item that this bill does
is a substantial addition to the duties
of the sheriff and his deputies
now don't think it would show come as a
shock to most people on this committee
that there's been a lot of um a lot of
is issues and a lot of controversy
surrounding federal law enforcement in
recent
time from the FBI to the
cpb they've been under heightened
scrutiny scrutiny for actions that have
been perceived by the
public it very much appears to me that
Doctrine within federal law
enforcement has shifted in recent times
to preferring high-risk tactical
operations in service of warrants often
utilizing explosive breaching deployment
of
flashbangs and it's moved away from the
more historical practices where they
would utilize maximum
deconfliction and maximum avoidance of
violence the
result from coast to coast has been an
increase in people killed in the service
of federal
warrants and an awful lot of
people that have had guns pointed at
justification as was historical practice
in this country for a very long time in
many
states it was up to the local County
Sheriff to know what was going on in
their County and to be a part of of the
law enforcement actions that were
happening so this bill places the
additional duty on the Sheriff's Office
to
observe but not participate directly
in the service of uh Federal warrants
and arrests and federal police actions
with the purpose of trying to protect
resident now somebody asked me a while
back so I'll address this right away
would that prevent them from if somebody
starts shooting at them doing anything
no absolutely not once you're getting
shot at you're no longer strictly just
in a law enforcement action you're in a
self-defense situation so that this
would not prevent The Taking of action
that finally it has been expressed to me
that there is some resistance regarding
perceived conflicting law on special
deputies while I don't entirely agree
with the interpretation I would ask the
committee that at the end of the day if
the section of this bill on special
deputies winds up being the sticking
point I would lend my support to an
amendment to strip that part out or even
to split the question on the house floor
because the portion of observing federal
police actions is of utmost importance
to me thank you I'd be happy to take
questions thank you um what do you see
the role of the of the sheriffs who are
there so let's we're going to have to
take it hypothetical a hypothetical the
um ATF is serving a warrant the
sheriff's hypothetically get notified of
it and they go in their role as
observers and they observe what they
deem to be a violation of the person's
rights what are they supposed to
do well first I I believe that they
would be far less likely to be a
violation of that person's rights in the
presence of a local representative of
the sheriff however if there were to be
what would appear to be a clear
violation of law I I would expect them
that unfortunately I think that you you
run into a Supremacy issue if they're in
servicing if they're serving a f a
federal uh warrant issued by a federal
judge
I'm just trying to see if that would
even I I'll have to research how that
would work out understood um further
questions representative Stone thank you
thank you for taking my question are you
aware of any cases in New Hampshire
where local authorities either municipal
or County or state isn't involved with
the execution of federal
warrants I am not aware of any where
they're not involved I am also not aware
of any when their involvement does not
include participating in the service of
the warrant as opposed OS to being there
as on behalf of the resident to assure
their rights are
protected thank
you are you aware of any other states
that have done
this as far as this type of Statute I am
not aware of any other states that are
have this in statute at the moment I am
aware that this was common practice in
the United States broadly up at least
until the early to mid 20th century
thank you um representative
Jam thank you Mr chairman
I I have several questions and I'll try
to limit them uh section one of your
bill deals with special Deputy
sheriffs um I recognize that present law
says a deputy shall not take any action
until their name is recorded by the
clerk and you've nullified that
requirement for special Deputy um one of
the questions that I have in relation to
that is are you aware of RSA 5
946 uh entitled Aid to officers which
states every law enforcement officer
encounters a need for assistance in the
ex execution of his office in a criminal
case or emergency situation may require
any person to render suitable Aid any
person who when so required neglects or
refuses to give such Aid shall be guilty
of a violation are you aware of that
law I I've been vaguely aware of that
law but I I don't see anywhere that law
conflicts with what I've put forward as
in cir cumstances that are emergent they
would not be prohibited from taking
necessary action they would only be
prohibited from participating in the
underlying law enforcement action for
that the that the federal officers are
undertaking
followup one
followup thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question I I'm not
saying that it conflicts with what you
proposing I'm saying that there's no
need for what you're proposing because
it's already in statute is that that's
my understanding do you believe that to
be true as well that would not be my
inter interpretation of that
Muse I'm
okay representative
Stone thank you again for taking my
question uh what law currently prohibits
any sherff from a special deputizing an
service what law prevents them from
doing so in a manner that would be
allowed them to operate immediately in
the event of a breach of the Peace um
that would be the section on um that
requires the reporting to the court
before they're allowed to take any
action which is what's repeated on this
or changed follow up the office of
sheriff is elected official correct yes
so if they do a deputization of an
individual that person's powers are
deputized
correct that is not the interpret ation
that I was given uh in speaking with a
sheriff just moments ago nor is nor is
it how I read the law
testifying thank you represent Muse
again thank you for taking my
question what sort of training do you
envision for these uncompensated
deputies the training there is no
training requirement because this is an
emergent process something that is done
in in a situation where there is a true
need to to regain if we're talking about
something like Insurrection we're
talking about a real problem that needs
to be dealt with right now and they
don't have the Personnel we don't have
time to put people through the police
academy hopefully there will be people
such as veterans maybe even XMS who can
circumstance see no further questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
noon
thank you for uh hearing my comments uh
I support this bill uh with respect to
uh federal law law enforcement being
required to um I'm sorry with respect to
uh uh federal law enforcement um doing
whatever they may be doing uh that the
uh Sheriff be required to participate or
or or or be there and I believe that uh
it's pretty clear example that the the
feds have become pretty uh polarized in
my lifetime
anyways um we have the examples of just
recently past couple years uh January 6
where people's homes are being raided
that just were mulling around the capito
building um uh you know by the FBI and
these agencies and the um and obviously
there was people in January 6 who you
know that particular event who had broke
the law uh and you know probably need to
be you know dealt with and do need to be
dealt with but there's just people who
are just hanging around and to where the
um having the sheriff be there when the
feds are doing something I feel is
important because the sheriff is the is
a constitutional officer he is the
highest lawful Authority on the county
uh from my what my understanding is a
sheriff uh has a higher authority than
the president than any any any federal
agent agency or agent within his County
and should definitely be present when a
federal Authority uh is involved in
doing whatever they're doing Serving a
warrant uh whatever and also this is an
added protection because um Sheriff's uh
would would likely maybe if anybody in
law enforcement is going to know like
the local people it's probably not going
to be the federal agents but it quite
possibly would be you know the sheriff
uh and also I would encourage everybody
to go shake their Sheriff's hand and
introduce yourself to him so he does
know know who you are
um and you know we have uh I I believe
an overzealous um you know sort of
radicalized uh federal government
anyways and uh the sheriff sheriff could
act as a buffer to any of uh you know
you see no questions thank you for your
testimony chair
Wright good
morning chairman Roy and members of this
committee I'm Sheriff Bill Wright I'm
representing the New Hampshire Sheriff's
counties I'm also the sheriff of belnap
County and I'm in my second term now uh
all all counties are represented
within the sheriff's Association at this
given time with the exceptions of uh the
vote if you will from uh straford County
which is which I believe is a vacant
seat right
now the New Hampshire Sheriff's
Association uh so all nine of us
sheriffs are opposed to House Bill
1017 we believe that this bill would
create uh some liabilities to our County
for each person that sworn in under this
manner and purpose we believe that uh
these people would no training no
formalized training uh as a certified
law enforcement officer uh creates his
own problems in the way that the current
Society is uh here in New Hampshire and
across the country we do believe that
this uh presents problematic uh
processes for us in the
future not being certified police
officers here in the state of New
Hampshire would mean that they have zero
arrest Powers so even if I was to swear
somebody in under a posi type uh
legislation they they have no rest
Powers uh therefore rendering uh this
conversation kind of moot um we
understand what the intentions of this
bill is but as it's written it would
create more liability and goes against
what the state has put in place for
requirements for us to actually become
certified police
officers we have a couple statutes that
are currently in place RSA 104 is what
exclusively covers sheriffs uh under RSA
1043 which is deputies an appointment it
talks about uh deputization under the
hand of the sheriff in that uh that they
cannot take action until it's recorded
uh at the Superior Court which again I'm
paraphrasing not reading the the statute
completely RSA
10412 which is requiring Aid so we have
the ability to request the aid of
anybody who happens to be in our
presence to help us uh do our process
which in essence is kind of what this
bill is trying to do I guess in some
manner but again arrest Powers uh we we
don't assert our authority to make
arrest Powers they're actually helping
us do something which would in my
opinion be that we are physically
present uh needing the help I.E
wrestling somebody on the side of the
road trying to get them into
custody we also have RSA 10427 which is
uh Deputy discharge so it requires us
sheriffs that if we do make an
appointment that anytime a deputy leaves
office in other words they resign quit
uh or we terminate them we have to serve
them with a um with an
actual discharge paperwork that
indicates that they're no longer um on
the Sheriff's Office on top of that
under RSA 10428 it talks about the
liabilities for deputies conduct not
only is the county on the hook for the
for the liability of the deputies the
sheriff themselves are personally liable
for each employee and as soon as I uh
swear somebody in they become my
problem I had read an article earlier
about uh establishing a
posi and
um I found it in business 2 Community
which uh was updated on July 7th 2023
and the article uh was put in there by
Connor Brooke and it talks about um posi
members and the government and uh how it
opens basically the government up for
liabilities if we were to just uh start
swearing people in and that they were to
automatically start operating as quas
police or or Deputy sheriffs um and it
was said in this article that uh that we
need to look at uh the liability both
between the civil and criminal aspect uh
as it relates to these people and there
was a quote in there it says if a
civilian were to be shot and injured or
killed by a posi member the county would
perhaps be criminally liable for that
action
as it's not unreasonable to assume that
a poorly trained individual who is armed
would not possess the necessary skills
and training to prevent an incident from
escalating to a tragic point I agree
with that
statement and I do believe that this is
a Pennsylvania based uh Sheriff's posi
because out in Pennsylvania they still
do that in Western
Pennsylvania RSA
106l which talks about police standards
and training Council and their Authority
and we as sheriffs are represented by by
Sheriff Conley right now as part of that
police standards and training Council so
we have a voice on that Council it
discusses the certification process of
law enforcement officers which my deputy
sheriff's a full-time law enforcement
officers and some of them are part-time
law enforcement officers and I have no
special deputies because I have no way
to pay them and everything according to
the law so uh so I have part-time Deputy
sheriffs RSA 106l describes what the
requirements are for us to have
certified police officers one of them is
a background check that takes time
normally it takes two weeks uh if not
longer depending on uh what their
background looks like we have to send
them to psychological evaluation to make
sure that they're they're okay to be
police officers we have to do a medical
screening and we send them to a a
physician to have a medical screening
done so these are just a few of the
requirements not to mention the physical
fitness section of it and all that and I
know that that bill I believe has come
before this committee at some point
those are things that we look at for
certification process um the sheriffs in
the state of New Hampshire at least nine
of us um out of the 10 positions are are
against this bill we're asking for it to
be ited as it relates to uh the way it's
written now I'll take any questions
thank you Sheriff
um you you addressed the portion of the
bill about the posy type situation but
the the sponsor indicated that he he
might be open to severing that with can
you address the part um with regard to
observing Federal officers enforcing um
their type of federal process
what yes so uh observing Federal
processes um again the federal laws are
set up and I I should not be required to
know what federal La is because I'm not
a Federal Officer I'm the sheriff of
bnap County and I enforce New Hampshire
state law so I can't uh sit back and say
that I I can make a determination
whether they're violating a federal law
or you know I can most certainly say
that state law uh as it relates to the
Constitution and people's constitutional
rights um we can see certain direct
violations of constitutional rights and
we can most certainly um Express to not
do that uh one of the things that does
come into play though is uh certain
constitutional rights that people
challenge uh it is not determined by a
sheriff it's determined by the courts in
our state and until it get gets before
the courts which would then require an
somebody to have an
offense made against them for them to
put the process in place to get into the
courts and then for the testimoni and
I'm sure that I would be called as a
witness and then we would go that
direction so I don't determine what
constitutional rights have been uh
violated per se as it relates to how
some people feel that they might have
been uh
suppressed as it relates to operations
in and around State uh and I could speak
specifically on my County uh every
Department every uh town and city in my
county has a police department those
police departments are no normally
notified by federal agents that they're
going to be doing a specific operation
now if they're doing surveillance
operations we don't have time to to get
every time they come into town and and
they're going to be doing surveillance
or something like that we have other
business that we're dealing with
especially in today's world where we're
having a hard time hiring Law
Enforcement Officers but they normally
do call us and say hey we're going to be
in the area or hey we're going to do
this certain operation uh in this
location and normally they call us for
some form of assistance whether it's
closing offroads or or being part of a
uh uh having a local connection to
whoever it is that they're dealing with
so there are normally conversations that
do occur now I can't speak for other
rural areas in the State uh that may not
have as many resources as I have in
belnap County but uh we're predominantly
notified when these events are happening
and traditionally uh if we're dealing
with the DEA US Marshals ATF they
normally include us to some degree
anyhow whether it needs to be in
legislation or not I don't know what
mechanism we would use to to address an
issue if if there was legislation in
place that required them to notify me
and me to be participative member and
does that mean me as the sheriff has to
show up to all their events because I
don't want to be up at 4:00 a.m. so when
they're doing their hits at 4:00 a.m.
does that mean I have to be there or is
it one of my represent you you know
representative department members and
then if we're there what are we doing
and what if they didn't notify us am I
supposed to go down and arrest the US
Marshall for not notifying us that they
were in the in the you know in the
county of bellnap in the city of lonia
doing a certain event so I think there
just some complexities there and it's
it's uh it's an uncommon thing for us to
have these problems that are being
presented as potential problems that I
I'm not seeing it as a problem and I
have not sat at the table with all the
sheriffs and we meet monthly for any of
them to complain about this as a matter
of fact most sheriffs have at least one
member associated with some form of a
federal government task
force and those members are generally um
also sworn so they have dual Powers is
that is that true yes they go through a
vetting process with the federal
government to to be to be basically uh
what they call special deputization
thank you um questions for the
sheriff seeing none thank you thank you
sure thank you is there anyone else
wishing to testify on this bill who has
not testified
yet seeing none I hereby close the
public hearing on HB
10117 and I open the public hearing on
HB 1026 relative to resisting arrest and
invite the prime sponsor to introduce
their
bill
hello again Mr chair members of the
committee this bill conceptually was
brought to me by a constituent of mine
who was also a law enforcement
officer this constituent made me aware
according to his own testimony to me
that in at least some places he has seen
it as common practice to affect
arrests that don't necessarily meet the
legal threshold to make an
arrest and when the arreste vigorously
objects as one might have expect of
someone being arrested without proper
cause they would then lean on a charge
of resisting arrest to justify the
arrest in a post Hawk
fashion now
I cannot independently verify whether
this is a thing that's happening whether
it's commonly happening or not I've been
told by this one officer that it does
happen however I can say just from a
simple reading of the law under
resisting arrest as it currently exists
it is set up specifically so that this
is something that can
happen so the question is should it be
able to
happen now my analysis would say that
all of our laws under our constitution
can be reasonably said to flow from our
natural rights to self-defense and to
self-determination the natural right to
self-defense is
unqualified it exists at all times
Against All
actors when one is the subject of
aggression that they did not provoke nor
initiate they have the right under law
under the
Constitution to
self-defense All actors means private
government now I'm not going to suggest
for a moment that it's wise to resist
arrest I'm not going to suggest for a
moment that I would recommend anybody do
it and I certainly would tend to
recommend that if somebody believes they
are being arrested without proper cause
court
however under current law they still can
be charged with resisting arrest even if
the arrest itself was found to be
unlawful or
unconstitutional and that seems to me to
be
unjust because they still possess that
right to self-defense no matter how wise
it may or may not have been to enact at
the
time so this law would change that
statute to make it so there is an
affirmative defense to a resisting
arrest charge if the arrest itself is
determined to be in a civil or rather in
a court proceeding to have been
unlawful and I believe that's how we
fixed this particular law that again was
brought to me by a constituent and law
enforcement officer and I'm happy to
take questions thank you thank you
um you have me at okay so if if someone
makes an arrest and it turns out the
arrest was no good if the person was
charged with the resisting arrest
depending on the level of that because
because in New Hampshire we don't have
an assault and battery and a police
officer statue resisting arrest can be
anywhere from you know this to punching
a police officer in the
face that's where we get kind of a
problem saying well you know it's that's
that's a separate thing and that can be
okay that I could see saying okay a
simple resisting arrest of um not
listening to the officer complying
versus physically assaulting an officer
do do you see what I mean that the
Nuance between those two things I do but
I think that can be reasonably resolved
through the normal circumstance that a
court undertakes to weigh the um the
reasonableness standard of self-defense
now again I wouldn't say that it's wise
to do so but if somebody in any
self-defense situation whether it's in
the street when they're being you know
being mugged or whatever the
circumstance if somebody comes up to
them and they they lay hands on them and
they push them and that person then
takes out a knife and stabs them well
that's no longer self-defense because
that You' you've now significantly
exceeded that gradient of force so
that's the kind of thing that would need
to be adjudicated there um and I don't
mean to imply for a second that I like
the idea of a police officer being
assaulted um I would say though that
it's still an injust situation because
the person retains that right to
self-defense so if it's going on a
Hands-On situation and they decide to
resist even though it may be
unwise I still would suggest they should
not be able to be charged with resisting
if the arrest was affected in an
unlawful for for without without
cause
okay see no further questions thank you
noon thank you for hearing my testimony
on this bill uh I support this bill um I
was arrested uh 20 years ago for
resisting
arrest and uh There Was You Know
multiple Court hearings and you know a
bunch of uh stuff that had happened and
ultimately uh the case was dismissed and
I filed a lawsuit and I was awarded a
sum that I'm not allowed to talk about
due to a
non-disclosure anyways um the uh you
know and in in my defense I to use uh
actual you
know uh that the arrest was unlawful and
unconstitutional and hence when that
evidence came to the court it was um you
know the case was eventually dismissed
uh this cost the taxpayers a lot of
money with the Judiciary and it also
cost him a lot of money with lawyers
defending uh a claim in federal court
and ultimately it cost a taxpayer's
money when uh was paid for my damages uh
something like this could um you know
alleviate a lot of that uh liability to
the
taxpayers uh I the property owners in
New Hampshire pay a
gross tax rate every year uh my property
tax is like $10,000 a year and several
of my neighbors are paying over $20,000
a year for property taxes uh which is
just you know insane so we need to the
legislature needs to do things uh like
uh vote for this bill or allow this bill
uh to protect uh taxpayers from uh
liability I don't know how much money
the uh New Hampshire's Department of
risk and benefit um pays out in
settlements um you know with you know
these kind of cases but I know that that
number just in general what they pay out
is uh pretty excessive it's it's
actually a horrifying number I suggest
uh maybe you know some of you guys look
into that um and uh it is I I am uh on
pretty good terms and good friends with
uh many current uh New Hampshire law
enforcement officers uh as I've made it
a point to meet and talk with them
regularly uh at events and and places
where I see them and uh a lot of them
have uh commented to me that the uh you
know charging somebody with um resisting
arrest you know is just basically
something they use when they don't
really have anything else to use and at
least today with um you know things like
uh everybody's got a camera and there's
cameras everywhere and in this
particular case where I was arrested 20
years ago it was at a gas station and uh
the the evidence was the surveillance
footage uh that you know what it took to
get it the Smith which was very hard to
come up with actually um but anyways uh
there's a lot of people law enforcement
who who who don't like how this can just
quite literally be used by someone in
law enforcement who has an act to grind
testimony the chair recognizes Chief
Charles
ratas good morning Mr chairman members
of the committee I'm Charles Raj I'm the
chief of the Hinsdale Police Department
um I do have over 20 years of police
experience I've worked in two different
states four different counties five
different municipalities including uh a
23-year career in the military police
Corps where I served all over the world
and uh I'm no stranger to unfortunately
encountering violent situations and uh
it's the goal of law enforcement to
avoid violence and I think that uh
especially the last four years there's
been a nationwide effort by police uh
Citizens Community members elected
officials at
deescalation at changing the way that uh
we approach violent situations and I
personally have witnessed many
interactions with police officers that
have gone through extraordinary efforts
to avoid violent situations sometimes at
risk to themselves um I think that it's
important that police officers have
legal protection so that if they are
forced to be in injected into a
situation where they have to take action
that they have that legal protection and
I think that a change to this statute
does exact opposite I think that it
actually could encourage people who
believe that they are correct and that
the police are wrong to take action um
frequently police encounter citizens at
their worst we encounter people in the
middle of Mental Health crisis we
encounter people that are impaired by
drugs and alcohol sometimes we encounter
people that are just outright upset um
due to the circumstances that they're in
and all of those situations are when
people are not making the best decisions
for themselves in that moment and uh I
fear that uh if people believe that they
have the ability to fight with the
police that they could outright just be
wrong and that all that that would do is
just in create a situation where it goes
from nonviolent and compliance into a
situation where it could suddenly be
violent and uh frankly there's already
consequences for police for that and uh
that are non-violent police and we've
just heard testimony they face lawsuits
uh police face termination from their
job um and police even face jail time
there's some serious consequences for
police officers we even now have a new
at the state level conduct Review
Committee you can complain to your chief
of police to your Town Administrator you
can complain to sheriffs there there's a
lot of avenues to uh to take out
grievances for a situation that isn't
right and uh personally I just believe
that adding more violence on top of uh
of a situation just isn't the right
answer thank you uh representative BRS
thank you Mr chairman could you give us
an example of how many how many people
while being arrested in your opinion
actually are resisting and how many are
actually charged with
that it's just been my experience that
uh there's a large number of people who
are arrested there's uh a great majority
of them are vocal and they're using
their uh their constitutional right to
voice their displeasure with that and
then most of them they go through the
process and if it turns out that they're
innocent then that's what the court
process is there for and uh a very small
number um actually results in violence
and I think that that number's changed I
think that the numbers overall violent
situations have gone down over the last
20 years I think we're we're trending in
in the right direction and I think that
we want to continue
that Chief if you could the ideal
situation is uh you speak to a citizen
the citizen has committed a crime worthy
of arrest you say to the citizen you're
under arrest turn around put your hands
behind your back we're going to the
police station the citizen complies you
get in the car we go it goes to court
court says officer you were wrong the
citizen has a right to go to court sue
the officer nobody got hurt in your
opinion would this statute possibly
change that would it would does it make
it legal for potentially someone who's
been intoxicated who comes out of the
bar at 1:00 in the morning same
situation you're under arrest you've
done AB orc put your hands behind your
back with would they not be under this
statute allowed to make their own
interpretation if it's a legal arrest
and then physically
resist I reading this statute I believe
that it it gives the individual a great
amount of personal freedom to make that
choice and um I I think that that's
dangerous because uh police officers go
through a tremendous amount of training
to make the decisions they make the
hiring process and the background the
polygraph the psychological examination
takes about four months then there's a
4-month training period in the police
academy then there's 4 months of field
training and then after that your
average police officer has to work in
his jurisdiction for about a full year
before they're trained just to get to
that point to make that decision and I
think that um given the general public
the ability to uh make the determination
on the spot to inflict violence on an
officer if they believe the officer is
wrong I view that as highly dangerous
and um there's a number of different I
mean we could speculate a lot but
there's a number of different ways that
this could turn out it could turn out
that now they're going to get felony
charges for an assault you know or in a
worst case scenario um a lot of people
in New Hampshire carry firearms
everywhere and it could be that it it
turns into a gunfight and um I think
that the the risk factor there is
extremely high thank
you represent wheeler thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question so to Pigg you back off of the
vice chair's question how many people in
your opinion who are charged with
arrest I think that there's a large
number who are and I think that usually
in prosecution and um there might be
another expert behind me to testify a
lot of times that's bargained away you
know and I think it and I think it
depends it depends on the prosecutor it
depends on the level of the offense it
depends a lot on what the underlying
charges too um so I mean I I don't have
any data set that I I could just give
you that other than just my inherent
experience but usually um I think that
the the prosecutors and the police are
out I'm all
good representative Stone thank you
Chief thank you for taking my question
in your opinion you would by removing
the uh duty to submit to arrest in the
state would that increase in your
opinion the injury level for officers
and offenders absolutely for both the
goal is and I think that most police
officers do a fantastic job of putting
more time into a situation to end up
with a nonviolent result and I think
that if we inject the possibility for
violence I think that you're looking at
both sides both the citizen or even uh
Witnesses or just the public in general
and the police officer are all risking
injury thank you
chief
Enders good afternoon my name is Step
Anderson I'm an assistant County
attorney of marac County I've been a
prosecutor for uh over 20 years I do not
support this bill I listening to the
sponsor talk I think that there are two
things that he two premises that that I
disagree with the the first one being
that you always have a right to
self-defense um I don't know that I I
agree with that premise that you always
have a right to self-defense and I know
at one point I talked about part one
article three of the New Hampshire
Constitution where there's a recognition
that when you enter into society you
give up some of your natural rights um
in order to benefit that society and
certainly that makes sense to me again
in the sense that if you're living in a
society we can't have sort of vigilante
justice that coexists with an organized
Society so you take your problems to
society um and they're resolved in the
ways that that the law sort of
instructs um the the second premise was
he said something about the police being
able to use resisting arrest as a way of
of taking people into custody and
further searching them or that type of
thing I don't think that's the case
either normally when the police uh
lawfully arrest an individual they can
search that person incident to to
arrest there's there is a case in New
Hampshire State versus
Baine that can be found at 151 New
Hampshire 803 it's a 2005
case um where Mr Bain ran from the
police the police chased after him they
thought he was selling drugs um chased
after him and eventually stopped him and
charged him with resisting arrest from
running from the police when they
searched him incident to arrest they
found that no surprise he had a large
amount of drugs in his pockets um the
New Hampshire Supreme Court said that
that was an unlawful arrest because they
didn't have reasonable suspicion at the
time they started chasing him to believe
he was selling drugs and we charged him
with resisting arrest and with
possession of a controlled drug with
intent to sell and the drugs were all
suppressed because the Supreme Court
said yeah normally you can do a search
incident to arrest but that doesn't
always mean you can and in a resisting
arrest case with an unlawful arrest you
specifically cannot do a search incident
to arrest um I I know that because I was
the prosecutor here in that case
unfortunately um
but there is another
case well there's another statute that I
would draw your attention to which is
RSA
5945 that talks about resisting arrest
it's under the arrest
section it says if a person is
reasonable ground to believe that he is
being arrested and that the arrest is
being made by a peace officer it is his
duty to submit to arrest and refrain
from using force or any weapon in
resisting it regardless of whether
there's a legal basis for the arrest
that was passed by the legislature in
1941 and has remained unamended since
then um to the extent you do change the
resisting arrest statute I would
encourage you to take a look at 5945 as
well and make sure that whatever change
you make which again I would discourage
harmonizes with that
statute there is another case that that
talks about this state versus h
it's
Haas
um that can be found at 134 New
Hampshire 480 it's a 1991 case where the
Supreme Court actually talks a lot about
your right to resist arrest for an
unlawful arrest and they talk about how
that used to be um under common law that
arrest and there's a quote in that case
that I'd like to read to you it says a
society which seemingly becomes more
complex with each passing day is
enlightened when its laws reflect the
high purpose to have apparent
differences between those who wield the
authority of government and those who do
not resolved in the courts or by some
other orderly process rather than by
physical confrontation on the street or
in the
gutter and I think that's really what
this comes down to is we don't want
people fighting on the street with
police trying to figure out if their
arrest was legal or not submit to the
arrest then it's up to the court and if
you were unlawfully arrested you should
sue the police and if the police
unlawfully arrested you you should
receive some damages for that um so I
would oppose the bill I'm happy to
usual see no questions thank you thank
you
narby this will be brief so uh there was
an
instant there's a a wide uh discrepancy
in how things are written and how they
actually happen in
reality uh this is one of them with
regards to resisting arrest there is a
group called The Noble 9 uh they were at
the governor's council meeting uh that
was uh engaged in discussing and
rejecting federal covid funds they were
all charged by the state police with
resisting
arrest there's video that exists in fact
there was a documentary made of them and
if you watch it you'll see none of them
resisted arrest yet they were all
charged so this is
what
this is what giving discretion opens the
door to and again there must be very
clearly defined lines otherwise
unaccountable people will take advantage
Stone chair recognizes um bill brigh
Police
morning chairman Roy and uh members of
the committee I appreciate you hearing
my testimony this morning my name is
Bill brigh I'm with the New Hampshire
State Police uh I'm a major I currently
oversee the detective uh all detectives
with the state police uh Chief rage and
attorney Henderson did a good job uh
with many of the points that I would
have brought up to the committee um the
only thing I would add is that I just
that the committee recognizes is that
the threshold for a police officer to
detain somebody is reasonable suspicion
in in other words if a police officer
has Reasonable Suspicion uh to believe
that a crime is being committed or has
been committed they have a right to
detain somebody to further question and
and investigate um the uh language of
the statute is actually resisting arrest
or detention so it's not always in in
while a police officer is affecting an
arrest
um where this can be charged so I would
just point out the uh those little
factors that um it's it's always the
right thing to do to comply with the
police while they figure out a situation
we feel that uh adding this language to
the statute and changing the statute the
way it is now will put police officers
troopers at risk uh more of a risk for
uh physical harm than they have at the
moment and it would encourage uh people
to resist arrest rather than just comply
with with what's going on at the time
and as the chief pointed out and
attorney Henderson and as uh the
committee has recognized there are
Avenues in place already to uh Rectify
those situations where a person is
wronged in in that
situation thank
you see no questions thank you for your
testimony thank you is there anyone else
wish to testify on this bill was not
testified on this bill seeing none I
hearby Clos the public hearing on house
Bill
1026 and open public hearing on House
1372 yeah um representative we're going
to take just real 10 minutes for a b
please
open a public hearing on House Bill 1372
and I invite the prime sponsor to
dear chair uh committee members uh for
the record uh my name is Yuri po of
representing mar mar 10 hookit and Dan
Barton uh House Bill
1372 is a common sense legislation
seeking to clarify and close the gap
between uh federal and state
legislation uh this bill defines and
prohibits within New Hampshire specific
withdrawal of medical help and other
situations of torture similar to how it
is defined and prohibited by the federal
law concerning officials actions outside
of the uh U us uh let us see the federal
um uh us code uh 18 chapter uh 113 C Tor
and specifically section 2340 capital a
torture uh uh section A says starts with
whoever outside the United States
commits or attempts to commit torture
shall be find under this title or in
present and so on uh that is the scope
of the federal uh prohibition of torture
VI this chapters only for acts outside
uh the United States uh this bill was
brought up to me as a constituent
request uh and you will hear additional
testimonial later uh in initially I was
going to refer it to another
representative but uh the more I thought
about this situation the more sense it
made to fix it uh one objection uh to
this legislation um that we hear is that
this specific prohibition of torture is
not needed this should be already
covered by broader statues uh
unfortunately when the system stops
working as it's supposed to any
ambiguity or lack of clarity can be
abused to receive
immunity uh we are not claiming that
torture is happening in New Hampshire we
just want a clear framework for the
future generation uh personally I'm a
big believer in the US and in New
Hampshire uh but many experts including
those in mass media um are less
optimistic they say the risk of danger
populism is on the rise the risk of
fascism is on the rise the risk of
authoritarianism is on the rise in the
US the experts say the US can elect
somebody like
Putin I personally do not say the risk
is so close but since I'm an immigrant
from Eastern Europe and follow Russian
politics let me tell you about Putin yes
uh he's torturing people yes uh he is
poisoning his political opponents yes uh
he is withdrawing their medical help
whether you believe that something like
that can happen after the next
presidential election or in a distant
future let's make this small effort to
stop the worst from happening uh US
senator from New Hampshire Jin
shahin supported Mikel sakash as he was
tortured in prison
she did so within a bipartisan group of
US senators calling on European country
named Georgia Mel sakash is a former
president of Georgia who was not afraid
to challenge Russian President Vladimir
Putin including during the war of
2008 but once Putin was able to exert
sufficient control over that government
sakash ended up in prison and showed
symptoms of poisoning Extreme Weight
Loss and overall lack of Medical Care
several times he he was brought to the
brink of dying to save your time I will
stop here but I'm ready to answer any
question please support House Bill 172
let us ensure New Hampshire stays
torture free thank
you thank you representative any
questions seeing none thank you for your
M taking a look at our um at our uh
assault statutes a lot of the things
that you would uh that would constitute
torture um are actually already illegal
uh under assault laws um so I I guess my
question for you is why do you think
thank you for a question uh I would
generally agree that there's a
significant
similarity um but there was a a reason
why uh Federal statue for torure exist
uh sometimes uh torure does not
necessarily uh leave
uh certain um injuries be observable
injuries behind it um and um uh there
are uh I believe need for clarity uh in
definitions so uh I I do believe uh
despite the similarity uh the Tor need
to be outlined
separately representative is there other
kinds of torture other than involving
physical
assault that you can think
of
um so in terms of uh this bill uh um if
you see section two uh um and uh
specifically section B uh numer three
there also lists the withholding
authoring withholding of medical
treatment or lawful medications
calculated to inflict severe medical
pain or suffering so it's not
specifically assault but uh it's uh what
I believe a reasonable person would
consider
torture thank you rep representative did
you have a follow-up representative
M do you have a followup or no I'm thank
you represent Stone thank you thank you
for taking my question prior to doing
this legislation have you looked at the
language of RSA 6314 631 and the other
assault
statutes uh briefly
could you clarify your question yeah my
question is is that most of the
languages uh as representative Muse said
very duplicative on the elements of each
one whether it be the criminal
threatening statute the assault statutes
they they're basically already covered
so basically this bill would just be the
same as these other statutes that break
it down in various sections that's
rsas
in in just in the interest of um time I
I believe the witness testified though
that there is certain aspects that are
not covered in the statutes for example
withholding of Medical Care um that
might be under a different statute just
quick followup is that uh you your
penalties are various which would be in
conflict between a class a felony and
Class B misdemeanor class a felony class
statutes thank you for question and
uh um yeah as I said I I believe it's
still needed that way if there's a but
if there's any conflict uh as you said
between classes of felonies uh I hope to
rectified uh it will be rectified with u
committee Amendment or something like
that thank
you thank you uh see no further
questions thank you for your
noon thank you again I'll make this uh
very brief um you know the purpose of uh
government as described in the
Constitution and the uh declaration is
to secure and protect the rights uh life
liberty property Pursuit of Happiness uh
this bill would uh be securing uh you
know the pursuit of happiness and and
rights of people by outlawing or Banning
or making a prose Prosecuting people
that commit torture obviously someone
who was tortured is being deprived of
Lights rights this government is uh
created to secure and protect therefore
Granger uh thank you Mr chair and uh
members of the committee I want to make
a single quick quick Point uh the
federal prohibition on torture only
applies outside of the United States um
and you can read it for yourself whoever
outside the United
States commits or attempts to commit
torture shall be fined under this title
or imprisoned etc etc uh the kit point
being that it there is a federal ban on
on torture but only outside of the
here hi good morning um my name is
Michael Peltier I am from uh now from uh
Hillsboro um uh prior to that from uh
hookset um so I wanted to um address uh
representative Stones Point um the
assault and related
offenses um
they would apply to acts of torture but
you can view this as a a sentence
enhancement for example so like uh
violence against Elders might have a be
considered a more serious crime than you
know a simple assault you know barall
for example um and I think that uh
police officials and people who are in
control of other people uh should have
uh more serious consequences for
committing acts of torture is defined in
the statute um now with respect to
um the the Bill's definition of torture
it very closely mirrors the uh in some
cases literally mirrors the definition
of torture in the federal statute uh so
I think it's in you know in alignment in
that regard um it does add the um with
denial of uh Healthcare and lawful medic
medications to the definition of torture
uh this is something that um it seems
like some of the re you know regimes
around the world uh such as Iran or
Russia under Putin um have worked out as
an exemption to as an exception to a way
for them to inflict severe U mental or
physical suffering on somebody without
uh falling under the the Treaty
definition of torture um now uh with
respect to recourse uh that someone may
have um
the uh oh well I should also mention
that the world Medical Association uh is
has decried uh the deliberate denial of
Health Care uh in Iranian prisons as
amounting to torture now um in
1976 uh the Supreme
Court said in uh a case called stelle
versus Gamble that a prison staff's
deliberate indifference to the serious
medical needs of prisoners amounts to
cruel and unusual punishment under the
eth
amendment um and also uh the United
Nations standard minimum rules for the
treatment of prisoner denying necessary
Medical Care uh violates that as well
and
um so there are a couple of recourses
that folks have in the United States
under federal law uh to address acts of
torture uh one is a civil rights lawsuit
uh which does not always hold the
individual
responsible uh for the ACT personally
accountable and arguably that person
should absolutely be held personally
accountable um another um as another
Avenue is in the on the criminal side is
um 18 USC 242 which is deprivation of
civil rights under color of law um
absent any bodily injury
uh or various other aggravating factors
it's only a federal misdemeanor uh that
has B basically up to a year prison
sentence uh and it's only a 10-year
felony even if botle injury results um
and you know I would I would submit that
that
um that the crime of assault committed
by a police officer against a prisoner
in their custody
um punishing that as say a simple
assault or an aggravated assault under
uh under the law with those lower
penalties uh violates uh the spirit of
article 18 of the New Hampshire
Constitution calling for punishments to
be proportional to the crimes um and
torture is absolutely a serious crime
everyone recognizes that around the
world and uh I think this bill gives us
the opportunity to uh as representative
poov uh said close that gap between uh
uh that exists in in federal
law now H happy to take any questions um
do you represent an organization I do
not no okay thank you representative
Stone thank you thank you for taking my
question I'm going to make it really
quick by the sounds of your testimony
you're seeing this as an enhanced
penalty for a government officials or
other type of organization not as a
regular everyday citizen is that correct
orrect correct yeah the definition of
torture uh presumes that it's a somebody
acting in official capacity under color
of law uh against a prisoner in their
you see no further questions thank you
for your testimony today thank you the
chair calls uh Mr Jeffrey Phillips New
Safety
anyone who hasn't testified yet who wish
to testify on this bill seeing not I
Clos the public
hearing and I open the public hearing on
House Bill
13:30 and recognizes the prime sponsor
introduce
sponsor
here good afternoon chairman and fellow
members of the criminal justice
committee for the record I'm Mark PR
representing Hillsboro 15 which is
Manchester Ward
8 I'm introducing House Bill
1330 that has to do with uh the
discipline system in the EMS
bureau
uh and the way I got involved with this
is I've been two people that I know
quite well have been in this s put into
this
system that at the time wasn't working
very well at
all the first case I'll tell you about
is she was my ex-wife she was a
paramedic
and did
a a documentation
era and she asked me to go with her when
she was being interviewed about what
happened she is at a paramedic level and
an EMT was the person who was like the
um investigator or the officer
collecting the facts and was going to
make a decision or recommend a decision
who was two levels down from her has no
idea of what was going
on uh she got
disciplined what I thought was a very
long time for a clerical Adder where
most people just get hey don't do that
again pay
attention um and what happens on their
website there's a a list that pops up of
everybody that's been disciplined
there my ex-wife passed away I said hey
can you take that down that would be
really nice nope there's no provision in
the law so in in section five
um that is there to give them the
opportunity a after five years it comes
off that visible list but stays in their
record and when you die it comes off
because because they're obviously not
coming back to get
hired so the other case I have is of a
person very
uh televised
case happened in
Manchester she waited 11 months to get a
determination of whether she was going
to be okay suspended or license
revoked she has family that she has to
care for and every day she did not know
would this be the day that I have to
give up my career because they finally
decided so after 11 months the state
finally said nope you absolutely did
nothing wrong you're good to go but that
was a long
time and finding out that really one
person gets to make that decision which
is the commission commer who isn't an
add I thought there should be at least
three people looking at if you're going
to be suspended or revoked shouldn't be
just one person should be three me three
peers looking at this I had it that they
were going to have the deciding vote in
my original
bill
but
after talking to the director telling me
that he has a lot of things in place now
and that maybe it should be just that
they consult with the commissioner and
the commissioner still makes the final
decision so that's what the amendment is
about it it just makes it an advisory
committee instead of the prior approval
it just removes the prior approval out
of the bill and down in section five it
removes public records to public list
website I have reservations about
bringing the amendment
forth but I told him I would give it a
go and see how it how it
goes uh and I understand the director
has done a great job he's made a lot of
changes but like I told him you're not
going to be here forever so the system
has to be able to move on when you're
gone and not revert back to what it was
cuz we were eating our own for a long
time down at the Bureau of EMS and I
don't want to see that go back to that
way so I'll conclude my
testimony
um and I'll take any
questions do um to the best of your
knowledge other medical professions how
are their licenses handled to is it just
one person who gets to decide it's
usually a board it's a board yeah and
know like through
oplc uh they have boards that hear that
there might be one person that's
Gathering facts but the facts are then
presented to the board you have the
ability to testify in front of the board
after they've gotten the
facts and that kind of thing and your
Amendment it it still leaves it in the
hands of the one person it just mandates
they consult with three people so they
you're right they're going to set up a
board that has three people of their
peer same level or
higher uh to hear that information make
a
decision because right now they have one
person taking in the facts it goes to
the director of The Bureau and then he
recommends to the commissioner and the
commissioner has the final
say I still have a little hurn with that
but we haven't accepted the amendment
yet representative s thank you and thank
you for taking my question um reading
through your bill and through the
amendment as well um I don't see
something and maybe I'm missing it that
would address the 11mon delay in getting
a response and I wondered whether it
might serve to have some sort of
timeline added that says within no more
than 90 days barring exceptional
circumstances for example oh I'd be
happy to add that um just to ensure that
that the timelines are more streamlined
um in terms of that process and then Mas
a followup thank you um I wonder about
um perhaps for the next legislative
session developing something that
requires qualifications for the
commissioner um so that they do in fact
have some medical skill or EMT level
skill to be uh more appropriate to make
those determinations I think you might
find that hard because the commissioner
is for the Department of Safety so
that's police Fire EMS so trying to get
one person that has all three of those
skills will probably be
impossible
but well he has one he has police yeah
right okay um any further
questions repr
Muse I would have been disappointed if
you didn't ask me a
question no no hopefully it's an easy
one um how often do things like this
come up is is this something that comes
up like a dozen times a year or
uh a few times a year I would say um and
and they have
uh I can't forget I can't remember the
term because it's gone right out of my
head it's like a a letter
of um warning or something like that so
that doesn't require any of this and
they're using that a lot more I guess uh
this director developed that
as a way to say hey don't do that again
right and so I understand that's being
used more but the higher levels
ones we don't make that many
mistakes right but the few that happen
and some of them are are
just a documentation area I I know like
in my ex-wife they changed the front
line first line
drug and she was always is used to using
what was the second line drug she
actually used the first line drug but in
her head she wrote the second line drug
right turned in the the proper bottle to
get refilled but because she wrote the
minds representative cite letter of
concern letter of what letter of concern
I think yes that's it thank
you see no further questions thank you
representative and the chair calls
Jeffrey
Phillips good afternoon Mr chair and
members of the committee um I thank you
for the opportunity to speak my name is
Jeffrey Phillips I'm representing the
department of safety um and I'm the
assistant director of the division of
fire standards and training and
Emergency Medical Services um my
comments will be u based on the original
bill um representative appr did U
provide us with an amendment so we'll
review that and provide feedback back to
the committee um as the original bill is
written the department of safety opposes
the bill for many reasons um we'd have
had conversations with representative PR
to share our concerns which um I believe
uh he attempted to put into the
amendment so we appreciate his um
communication on that so currently right
now the department of safety has ability
to immediately suspend EMS license uh
EMS providers uh their right to practice
if it is determined that the EMS
provider causes an imminent uh threat to
Public Safety um or public health with
the original bill that's currently there
um it adds a layer to the to have this
go towards the panel which would delay
the suspension of uh a provider's
license which could immediately um allow
this person to continue to practice and
jeopardize uh Public Safety or the
welfare of individuals that are calling
for assistance secondly the original
original ordering of the bill requires
this board to review all uh renewals of
licenses which I believe was an
unintended consequence of the original
bill um this would delay the licensing
of uh 5,500 licensed providers that
don't have any disciplinary action um so
I don't think it was the original int
ENT of the bill but based off the
wording that was our interpretation of
it uh the bill also authorizes as
representative PR talked about the
removal of lenses from the public uh
from our public records um the original
I think the the amendment did cover this
it changed it from public records to
public list um the public list that's
posted um we opposed to having those
individual lenses records removed
entirely from our
system additionally RSA 5313 authorizes
the commissioner to deny an application
for issuance or renewal or to take
action on license if the individual is
found guilty of violating
153 um the bill would require
pre-approval from the panel um as
representative PR did uh his Amendment
does change this to an ad essentially
consult uh with the board prior to the
commission making decision um by having
it a pre-approval this could create a
situation where there's a stal M and
there's nobody that has the final
authorization so if the commissioner um
chooses that yes he feels based off the
the the evidence that the person should
be suspended or revoked or something to
that effect and the panel doesn't um
really that uh individual lensey could
be um in a state of limbo and not
knowing what's going to happen um lastly
over the past several years we've taken
great effort to try to streamline the
process in 2013 there were 24
investigations that La uh that resulted
in some form of sanction the majority of
them as we spoke before uh that came up
before turned into letter and concerns
um which does not get posted on the
list uh approximately most of these
investigations took about 6 months on
average um the length of time an
investigation takes really depends on
the complexity um as well as um the
amount of Investigations that the
division is currently uh looking at I
believe currently right now we have like
38 uh open investigations going uh one
of those investigation has many many
providers um so it really depends on
coordinating schedules doing interviews
um and lastly the the creation of this
panel uh will insert a another step in
the process um so once the the the
commissioner makes their determination
makes his determination before it would
be final would go before this board um
and it would just lengthen the
process willing take any
questions thank you um what comment if
any does the department have on the on
the issue of one person having the final
say over someone's um someone's career
basically it's not just a job it's the
rest of their career um where most other
professions have a board or a panel of
people experts who actually look at this
thing yeah overall the Departments are
not opposed to to the panel um it's the
stuff that was outlined um as of right
now as representative PR mentioned we
the current director has spent a lot of
time over the past two three years
revising the the investigative process
um internally the investigator does
their investigation U poses that
information to the director and the
bureau chief of EMS uh currently both of
them right now are both paramedics um
the bureau chief of EMS is required to
be a paramedic has part of a job
requirement um before this information
goes to the commissioner to make a final
decision it's vetted by um the senior
staff of the division um to provide that
recommendation to the commissioner so
it's not necessarily a formal board but
um there is a recommendation um provided
at the par at least the paramedic level
um going to the commissioner so it
sounds like he's taken a lot of steps to
professionalize that um under his watch
or is it he or she
yeah so but the problem I that I see is
um as representative pu said if that
commissioner leaves the next
commissioner could undo all that um and
it could just go back to one person um
if if it was a panel of of individuals
who had to vote on taking a a step as
far as just revoking a license and the
commissioner were a member of that panel
and it was an odd number panel would
that not also be okay or would do you
see that is a
problem like the Board of Medicine has
to vote to take away a doctor's license
that's correct So currently the the one
difference between the border of
medicine and the uh the EMS license is
the Department of Safety is responsible
for 153 which the commissioner is
responsible for issuing the licenses
versus the Board of Medicine is
responsible so essentially the The
Entity that is responsible for issuing
the license is responsible for revoking
the license so in this specific case
that's why the commission has that
Authority okay thank you further
questions representative
Newman what's the usual impetus for
these investigations is it from within
the organization or from outside of the
organization um it's actually never
within the organization um it's um 100%
of the investigations that are uh looked
into are based off a public complaint so
a public complaint could be a another
EMS provider it could be a patient that
was provided care or something to that
effect we're not looking um for issues
uh uh it's always brought to us from the
outside of our organization thank
you with regard to the uh other
representative's question um
streamlining or or putting a a Time
certain to complete an investigation of
90 days do you feel that that would be
far too short or is is do you see an
issue with that um it's a it's partly
resource issue um at the division um
currently we have one time one full-time
investigator and a part-time
investigator um so and a lot of it
really depends on the complexity of the
case some of these cases can be
significantly complex in regards to like
multiple people that are part of the
same incident um so 90 days would
definitely be uh in some cases
um some of these probably could be done
in 90 days um but really depending on
the complexity of the case um there are
some that uh extend past 6 months um as
the representative said we had one that
was at 11
months what percentage are suspended
immediately in other words some of these
people continue to work still while
they're under investigation and they're
able to continue making their their
salary to feed their family but some of
them are suspended sarily right away
during the investigation uh that's
correct uh if you give me one
second
I don't know if I have it in the written
testimony um if I I did just see the
information I believe in for 2013 there
were four individuals that had an
immediate suspension done um and most of
them are due to a uh felony level arrest
um sexual uh sexual assault domestic
violence um something to that effect it
has to be a severe where um you know I
mean there there's a threat to the
public of this person being in the back
of the ambulance with an underage
individual or something to that effect
thank you representative saor thank you
and thank you for taking my question um
I'm curious I learned this earlier this
morning that you know something like 80%
of the Departments of the are volunteer
versus professional uh paid people so
I'm just wondering if there's any
distinction in how people are um
evaluated for their certification based
on volunteer and paid status uh from our
perspective no um all EMS license
providers are treated the same uh
they're responsible for the same level
of care whether you're a part-time
paramedic or a full-time paramedic um
State there's Statewide protocols that
outline the type of care that you are uh
required to give um and I mean full-time
paramedics have the ability to practice
more often um but the level of
expectation when somebody shows up on
scene um is for them to be able to
provide that level of care that they're
licensed to um so it it has no
consideration in regards to whether
they're full-time or
part-time is the department um
requesting more time to evaluate the
amendment that was proposed uh we would
appreciate that yes okay thank you how
long do you need um week yes thank you
and if 90 days
um see you no further questions thank
you for your testimony thank you um
anyone else wish to testify in this bill
is not testified see no one I hereby
close the public hearing and with that I
hereby open the executive session on
House Bill 1017 relative to the
appointment of Sheriff's and I move
inexpedient to legislate do I have a
second
second you can do it who did it it
repr was actually me but I was giving it
to someone else
want um I'll speak to my motion uh this
bill regarding the sheriff's uh the
sheriff's Association every single
Sheriff that's currently holding office
in the State uh found it inexpedient to
legislate or requested it be inexpedient
to legislate um it seems to want to
hearken back to the good days of let's
get the poshi together and ride out and
get them um unfortunately those are not
the days we live in we have National
Guard now available to assist in
emergencies of that number of people um
randomly deputizing people just sounds
like um a bit of a nightmare with regard
to asking the sheriffs to oversee
Federal investigations and law
enforcement actions I don't I just don't
even know where to begin it seems very
difficult to first of all it's an
unfunded mandate on the counties they
don't have the staff even if they did
you're going to get into arguments
between the feds and the sheriffs about
what they're doing whether it's
constitutional when the sheriff doesn't
have the access to the investigative
files and what they're dealing with it
just sets up a nightmare scenario that I
I just I understand and appreciate the
the sponsors concerns regarding certain
federal actions that we've all seen
however that as frustrating as it is it
has to be dealt with at the federal
level and we cannot micromanage the
federal government um from this level as
much as we would like to on occasion um
whoever seconded would you like to speak
to your motion who was
it who who seconded that I thought it
was no did you representative n did you
second represent oh great Stone can
whoever yeah Mr chair uh speaking on my
second we did hear the testimony from
all the sh the sheriff that all the nine
sheriffs currently serving agree that
it's a bad Bill uh in addition I think
it was brought up that uh levels of
certification come into play if you're
carrying a gun in New Hampshire you're
obligated to meet the requirements of
police DeMent training along with the
additional trainings therefore I think
it is a practical matter no sheriff is
going to be putting anybody they find to
be unsuitable as a
deputy further discussion representative
Manion thank you Mr chair yeah in
addition I think that they would also
need to be physically fit so they would
have to pass a physical fitness Entrance
Test and possibly an ongoing three-year
thing yeah that that that would be
highly important U representative s I I
I concur I I was actually asking
representative tenar if you know should
something like that happen here would I
need to be assigned to the water Brigade
water bottle Brigade and I I don't think
I'm competent to defend our our
protections with that you would be
promply handed a Remington uh 870
shotgun and sent to the front I would be
less confident um further further
discussion representative Jam thank you
Mr chairman uh during the testimony I
asked about 5946 which requires a
citizen to render Aid to a law
enforcement officer and that was brushed
off um the first part of this bill was
actually uh if there was an emergency
that that they could appoint special
deputies they don't need to they can
already ask members of the public to act
accordingly so I I agree with the itl
recommendation any further
discussion scitech I'm not sure this is
worth it but I'd like to I'm more
impressed with the read reasons not by
the fact that they all so what they all
do it but I want to know their reasons
so thank
you see no further discussion I ask the
cler to call the role the motion on the
floor is an expedient to legislate Vice
chair roads yes representative Pratt yes
representative scitec yes representative
PR yes representative janen yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tzar yes representative
Harry cther yes representative Muse yes
representative rung yes representative
Bradley yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative sik yes representative
wheeler yay chairman Roy chair votes yes
20 20 inexpedient to legislate any
objection to consent it will go on
that I close public uh excuse me the
executive session on House Bill 1017 I
open the executive session on House Bill
1026 I make a motion of in expedient to
second Manion Manion got that one um
I'll speak to my
motion this bill as it's written
technically clearly would allow citizens
on the side of the road in the middle of
the night regardless of their state of
inebriation or sobriety to decide
whether or not something an officer was
doing was constitutional and physically
resist and assault the officer based on
their interpretation of the law at 3:00
in the morning after leaving a bar um in
it's just a recipe for disaster and I
just don't think we should even
entertain
it thank you I agree with everything you
just said in addition uh I disagree with
the see everyone has a right to defense
at all times in this scenario you have a
you have a duty to submit to the arrest
and you can handle it later on in court
so I agree thank
you
discussion who represent wayer thank you
Mr chairman I just wanted to say that I
appreciate what uh my friend
representative Manion and you just said
um I do think and I'm voting with the
itl on this I do think that there might
be in some future legislature uh some
benefit to looking at the resisting
arrest statute and seeing if we can
clarify that to make it so that no
officer is using the resisting arrest uh
charge to as was testified to scoop
somebody up who might just be you know
belligerent yeah it seems to me you have
to have a an arrest that's legal to
actually resist it in the first place
that's why it's important last year we
we came together and we passed the the
assault and bad of police officer bill
because that is where you draw the line
is when you're assaulting an officer
resisting arrest seems very vague to me
we passed that bill unfortunately our
friends on the other side decided to I
don't even know what to do went into
that Abyss that some of our bills often
go to um further discussion seeing none
and ask the clerk to call oh the clerk
wants to
discuss thank you Mr chair um I was just
going to say that I would support this
bill if we added an amendment to um make
assault against police officers illegal
like we did last year yeah I think I
agree I I think first of all we have to
discover where it went and see where the
status of it is and um if if not we be
we can co-sponsor another one next fall
if we all survive the election
um um with that I'd ask clerk to call
the role motion on floor is an expedient
to legislate Vice chair Roes yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec yes representative PR yes
represent representative Janan yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tanzar yes representative
harri gther yes representative Muse yes
representative rang yes representative
Bradley yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative sing yes representative
wheeler chairman Roy
chair votes yes
20 and thank you with that 20 any
objection to consent seeing none will go
on consent I got the report on that one
too um I believe uh okay with that yeah
did we what did we do with 1017 did we
put that on consent or not yes we did
thank
you um Mr chair yeah who's oh right here
this up um uh just just a point of order
I'm not sure if bills that have a fiscal
note are allowed to go on consent do you
know um some of them do and some of them
don't I think the clerk will determine
whether or not our consent vote is Val
or not um because some of them say they
have a fiscal note and then you look and
there's no money I I don't know it's
killed anyway yeah if it's killed anyway
it's itl yeah it doesn't matter I think
okay thank you yeah but you may be
correct I don't know I'm sure the if
he's watching will let us
know um with that I uh opened the um
executive session on House Bill 1372 and
I move in expedient to legislate may I
have a second representative har Gite
seconded I'll speak to my motion um with
regard to prohibiting torture the I
believe wholeheartedly in the good
intent of the um sponsor however that
being said every single thing that we
could think of is already covered in
statute the reason it says outside of
the United States and the federal
statute is because within the United
States we have laws that prohibit all of
the things that could be considered
torture whereas in other countries
someone might take someone to a country
that doesn't have a law that covers for
example starving somebody or withholding
medical care or assult so that's why
that's there in my belief I do not
believe this is necessary and um it's it
seems more political than probative
with that representative GA would you
like to speak to your
second I just wanted to add that um RSA
631 did cover most of this as
well that's in his
bill open for discussion representative
um
scitec can't neutr
system and not any more than um um
Weight Watchers I don't think um
representative Reed I think that we need
to look at this a little closer given
the current Administration I want to
make sure I think we it would be in our
best interest to make sure all our laws
are airtight as far as torture because
um we just assume that it's not going to
happen but I think um we really need to
to be sure that we're covered I would um
I'm not aware of um any torture
allegations under this Administration
having said that the um us I would point
you to us code um 1983 it says whoever
under the color of
Law deprives and paraphrasing deprive
someone of their rights under the
Constitution they are criminally liable
no that's the Civil one where you can
pay triple damages there's also a
criminal law that uh covers that so that
means if a government official because
you're talking Federal does something to
deprive someone of their rights under
the Constitution they're criminally
liable so that would Inc include torture
yeah absolutely um representative
wheeler thank you Mr chairman and I
respect yours and representative goth
right's position on this um I'll be
voting against the itl and for uh the
legislation to prohibit torture I uh
very passionate believer in what the I
think the United States has become and
um or against what the United States has
become when it comes to how we treat uh
foreign combatants and uh uh people who
have been picked up and foreign foreign
entities and I think that um uh with
George W bush running around making
paintings about veterans I think it it's
uh incumbent on us to start the
conversation about torture what it means
and I will see your George W bush
paintings and raise you Hunter Biden
painting there you go well and I don't
want to take out George W bush as he's
driving up to Kenny bunkport but I think
it would it wouldn't be nice to put him
on his toes a little bit when it comes
to uh some of the actions taken by the
federal Administration in the early
2000s and I think I would agree that
some of the things that went on at gitmo
are quite questionable however again
that's why it's outside the United
States and if there was torture they
that's why they kept them there and
didn't bring them here because once you
get here you have civil rights well
absolutely I think this would be just a
good sort of put them on their toes sort
of thing again that's why I said it's
more political than probative it makes a
statement and if you wish to support
that that's fine um representative Stone
thank you I spoke with the uh Prime
sponsor after the hearing and uh I
advised him of my concerns with it and
he reassured me that the intent that he
had was for government officials
government entities political
subdivisions which was not spelled out
in the bill he thought the underc of law
would have covered it but for most
people I don't know if they picked up on
that or not but his prime goal was
government entities and I kind of told
him that as far as I was concerned at
this time the bill is not ready for
prime time and that if he wants to work
on it he should do that but I I just
can't see the language of it sustaining
a house vote this time
around representative
cther I think the question was to him um
was he specifically talking about
yes prisoners yeah okay so people that
were in custody yeah that's what the
about I still think that that's covered
by our current representative Pratt
would we we be better off to hold this
in some fashion as opposed to killing it
it I would entertain that but in the
second year of bium we really can't um
like retain bills that you either have
to act on them or not um and if I were
to do for example say a study committee
out of it that would put us in right in
the middle of the campaign I mean if you
wanted to work on on it
I'm I'm open to the will of the
committee representative wheeler just to
representative PR point I think he could
table the legislation and then it would
be his legislation and he could work on
an amendment on on the floor and then
I'd be in fav table it yeah or yeah you
that okay representative uh rhs thank
you Mr chairman um I don't know how many
bills other committees have and I do
realize how many we have and we hear
unfortunately a lot from a sponsor that
sits in front of us and the very first
thing they say is I would entertain an
amendment I if you want to do that it is
not you know it is not our job as a
committee to go in and make somebody's
Bill to the point of passable a
reasonable Amendment if we hear
something you know upon the testimony
that's one thing but you know when you
bring a bill in front of us and you're
intense
is for a law that that's a really big
deal and I think that a lot of people
sponsors need to take a minute and step
back and realize that and do the due
diligence that is expected when you're
trying to change or make a law and not
expect other people to do it so
therefore I I will be supporting the itl
and if anybody wants to write the bill
correctly they're welcome to do so and
we'll look at it next
year yeah just a reminder we do have
latest count 56 bills and that without
any getting referred to us um so we if
you guys want to get out of here in time
to work on your Tans um I would suggest
we move along quickly representative
Stone thank you I'd also like to point
out that much of the language in the
bill is prohibited by federal statute
and State Statute in itself therefore
it's duplicative as far as regards to
prisoners there are enhanced penalties
for people in custody that if there is a
Act of simple assault or other charges
that are brought for them that they do
face so therefore even even on its face
this entire bill is duplicative of other
laws that are in existence and if it's a
federal case the feds are going to
handle jurisdiction if it's a state case
state will have jurisdiction thank you
represent I sensed you want yeah I I
intend to support the itl but um the one
thing that does give me pause is the uh
uh the inclusion of the in the Bill of
severe uh mental pain and suffering so
look at our looking at our assault
statutes and some of our other statutes
um it doesn't appear that that is that
that is covered um but thinking it
through um that's something um you know
for me to make a decision on that is
going to require more information uh
than I have here at this time um and the
information that I have at this time uh
basically uh leads me to think that if
if this is something that we want to do
I think I think uh this is something I
think the sponsor and the folks who
support him need to kind of go back uh
and to really think that through in
terms of what it means uh not only for
this statute but for other statutes too
um uh but for us to uh to pass this uh
the the way that it is now I think would
be a mistake thank you and I agree that
there are a lot of ways that you could
keep someone incarcerated without
injuring them that would still be
torturous um and and have mental um
effects on them I just don't think to
your point this this is fine-tuned
enough to be that vehicle and given our
time constraints I do not think that we
to your point also could give it what
it's due to actually look into it
representative wheeler really quickly Mr
chairman thank you I just wanted to say
to representative Road's point that uh I
have no intention of making all of us
stay and work on this on this bill I
wanted to as I was bringing up the
tabling motion was for the sponsor if if
the sponsor wanted to use some of his
time to readjust this bill table it
rework it and bring it back to us I
think that would be acceptable I and I
would also say that I've already got my
tan so I can uh work on this leg as much
as as much as needed I like you know
so I think you have some uh room to uh
darken um given that I would also if the
if the sponsor asked me to I would
actually make the motion to table it but
um we'll see what happens uh that's it
for the discussion I would ask the uh
clerk to call the role please motion on
the floor is inexpedient to legislate
Vice chair roads yes representative
Pratt no representative
scitec representative crew yes
representative janen yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed
representative Stone yes representative
tenar yes representative Harriet gther
yes representative Muse yes
representative rang yes representative
Broadley yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative salig yes representative
wheeler nay chairman Roy chair votes yes
um that can't go on consent now we have
three um representative wheeler would
you like to write The Minority Report I
can do that Mr chairman okay and I'll as
um with the other two I'll take the
report on the
itl V on titles you vote on content um
what yeah it was itl um and with that I
close the executive session
what was the final votee 17 to three 17
to3 and I will see you all
vote